مساء الخير على حضراتكم مره ثانيه معلش
يعني بدا ثم قطعنا ثم عدنا اليكم لكن احنا
مستغرقناش غير عده ثواني قليله يعني للي
لسه حاضر
احنا ان شاء الله تروحين موضوع بعنوان
عام 2023 بدايه ساخنه وهي فعلا بدايه
ساخنه على المستوى السياسي والمستوى
الاقتصادي وفي مجموعه من الملفات المهمه
على المستوى الاقليمي لكن هاستنى لما تيجي
اسئله حضراتكم وبعدين ناقشها من خلال
الاسئله
وان ارمي مان اهلا اهلا بك يا اخونا بحبك
سيد ااا الجميل او لا انا كنت اتمنى اكون
جميل بس انا قبيل تصغير جبل يعني الجبل
ليتل معهم ثاني يبقى جوبير ربنا يخليك
ويحفظك على كل حال انا عمري ما بتجيش فرصه
ان انا اقول الاسم يعني مساء الخيرات اهلا
وسهلا
ربنا يخليك
كده تخلينا يوتيوب كيدز يا استاذ ما كانش
العشم كلها سنه وابقى 18
ماشي خلاص اوكي
تمام الدردشه اشتغلت اسلام الله يخليك
لماذا لا تقوم روسيا باستخدام قوتي
العسكريه الحقيقيه لانهاء صناعها مع
اوكرانيا ده هشام اخونا
هو اخونا يا هشام القصه دي مطروح احنا
طبعا طرحناها بالتفصيل في حلقه متسجله وفي
حلقه برده كانت لايف هي القصه باختصار ايه
الاهداف المطلوبه ايه في لو كان الهدف هو
تدمير اوكرانيا عن فكره ابيها كانت
المساله انتهت يعني مثلا لما روسيا حبه
اللي هي تخرج العراق من الكويت
ما كانش ابدا ابدا الهدف ان هي تخرجها
لانه هي وصلت الضرب حتى بعد الجيش العراقي
اولا لتدمير البنيه التحتيه العراق لتدمير
الجيش العراقي حب تجرب اسلحه جديده في خصم
اضعف بكثير ده انا بدي كمثال بالنسبه
لروسيا ما كانش في البدايه ده الهدف الهدف
كان مبني على حسابات ان اوكرانيازل رشا هي
روسيا الصغيره وبالتالي هي بس محتاجه انه
الضغط حتى تعود الى قطاع الروسي ان مازلت
اذكر بعض المحللين الروس اللي هم كان
عندهم قناعه بي ان المهمه عباره عن
نزهه
بيسخروا من الحقيقه ما كانش في سخريه
كبيره يعني لان هم حتى بيتكلموا وكان
وقتها بيكلموا الصحفيين الاوكراني على
استنكار يعني ان انتم بتقولوا هنقاوم
هتقوموا مين ده احنا واحد فكان في قناعه
كانه كمان في قطاعات طابور خامس في
اوكرانيا سوف يضع السلاح وسوف يرحب بالروس
فكل دي حسابات حتى لما ثبت ان في مقاومه
كان في همم يقين انه يمكن باستخدام قوه
عسكريه معقوله تحقيق الاهداف واسقاط حكومه
الاسكي والسيطره على قطاعات كثيره وما فيش
داعي ابدا لتدمير مدن احنا عاوزين تنضم
الينا يعني ف- ما كانش كانت الحسابات هكذا
دلوقت الصوره اختلفت
وعاوز اقول لك برده على حاجه يعني الناس
اللي هم معتقدين ان حتى لو ان روسيا ما هو
طبعا اذا استثنينا فكره انك يعني تدمرها
عن فكره ابيها يعني مش ممكن يبقى مساله
ورده يعني لانه يعني مش هضربها بقنبله
نوويه يعني فكره ان دوله كبيره تهزم دوله
صغيره
مش دايما المساله همم ميسوره بل بالعكس ده
في دراسه اتعملت يمكن همم اتمنى ان احنا
نعرضها في اقرب فرصه همم استاذه امريكيه
باحثه ما كانتش لسه استاذه انما عمل
الدراسه لطيفه جدا رصدت فيها
عشرات الصراعات في ال
50 سنه اللي فاتت دي وكثير منها انتهى
بهزيمه الدوله الكبيره في الدوله الصغيره
لاسباب منها انه الحافز عند الدوله
الصغيره اكبر من الدوله الكبيره منها انه
ال ال الدوله الكبيره ما عندهاش استعداد
ان هي تلقى خسائر كبيره قوي زي ما حصل
الامريكان مثلا في فيتنام ولو صرعت طول
كتير وبالمناسبه زي نصين خسرت في حربها في
فيتنام سنه 79 اظن بس دي صراع ما هواش
مشهور قوي على العموم
الصراع مستمر
ويبدو انه سوف يطول كثيرا
[موسيقى]
الصوت ممتاز طب الحمد لله مساء الخير سيد
جبيل مساء الانوار خالص تحياتي الله يخليك
جورج
والله يخليك امين او امينه انا انا اسف مش
متاكد من الاسم يعني يا ريت تقول لي
مش واضح بالانجليزي
انا اظن ان روسيا وامريكا ده يثبت ان
روسيا وامريكا متفقين على غزو اوكرانيا
وهذا قرار امريكي لتدمير اوروبا وايضا
الاقتصاد العالمي لبناء
لبناء واحد جديد يثبت كل الاحترام لك انا
مختلف معك
من حيث الاستنتاج لكن انا نفسي استغل
الملحوظه دي علشان اطلب من حضرتكم انه
اعاده النظر في مثلا الوصول الى استنتاجات
على الاحساس يعني مثلا يجي حد يقول لي وده
كثير بيتقال ايران واا واشنطن وطهران دول
اصدقاء ودي تمثيليه ممكن بس هل عندك في اي
دلائل يعني اللي بيقولوا
ان في صراع ما بين روسيا والولايات
المتحده والصراع لا يمنع احيانا هم يتفقوا
على بعض اوجه التعاون حتى الان ما في سفير
في كل بلد لا يمنع انما الدلائل واضحه جدا
على الاعداء فاللي يقول ان في عداء مبني
على منطق واضح
انما اللي يقول ان ايران والولايات
المتحده اصدقاء ان العلاقه ما بين اسرائيل
والايرانيين سليمه انه الامريكان
والايرانيين
بيتامروا على الدول العربيه ده استنتاج
عشان تقوله يفضل ان يكون في دليل دليل
مبني على واحد اثنين ثلاثه وليس مجرد
احساس ده في قضايا كثيره يعني مساء
الخيرات عادل مساء الخيرات يسعد مساك ربنا
يخليك ما هي توقعاتك للاقتصاد الاوروبي
انت عامل الليتنسي يا ماندو انا ماشاء
الله
يعني لا تنسى بحيث ان هو لو قدرنا نعمل
الفروق ما بين سؤال وسؤال بحيث ان البث
الاسئله ما تجريش مني ما هي توقعاتك
للاقتصاد الاوروبي بالخصوص المانيا ده
رفيق الاقتصاد الاوروبي طبعا همم
كله بيعاني معاناه انا على المستوى الشخصي
انا ما اظنش ان انا قابلت اي حد او اتكلمت
وانا اي حد كان يمكن ان يتخيل انه اوروبا
تعاني بهذا الشكل
التوقعات قالتها قريتها صندوق النقد
الدولي مش محتاجه سيد او محمود قالها
البنك الدولي قالها صندوق النقد الدولي
وقالت ان انا بتوقع انه ثلث اقتصاديات
العالم سوف تدخل في ركود
الركود يعني ريسيشن وفي فرق بين الريسيشن
والكاسات اللي هو اكثر عنفا ما فيش حد
بيتوقع ان يكون في كساد ولكن همم ريشين او
ركود يعني تباطؤ في اقتصادي وانه همم انه
حتى الدول التي لم تدخل في ركود في مئات
الملايين في هذه الدول سوف يشعروا بوقود
يعني معنى كده ان المعاناه هتكون على
الجميع اصل الركود معناها ايه انه النشاط
الاقتصادي بدل ما بتحقق مثلا
اهو في ناتج محل اجمالي لكل دوله عاده في
الظروف العاديه بيكون كل سنه في نسبه نمو
انت حققت الناتج المحل الاجمالي بتاعك زي
مثلا 100 مليار
عندك الزياده السنه الجايه نسبه نمو 1%
يبقى انت حققت 101% ده الطبيعي لان دائما
في نسبه باستثناء دول قليله في زياده في
نسب السكان انت كالعاده سكانك كذا في
الغالب بتزيد
في الغالب الناس مستواها بيتحسن بيتعب
بيشتغل فبيتحسن فعاوز يعيش حياه افضل
وهكذا فلما يكون نسبه النمو ضعيفه انت مش
كويس لما تكون نسبه النمو زي ما هي انت
كان ناتج المحل الاجمالي بتاعك 100 والسنه
الجايه 100 امر سيء ان انت بدل ما كنت 100
تبقى 99 يعني انكماش بنسبه 1% امر مخيف
فده هو المقصود بكلمه
ريسيشن او انكماش
انما في دول ممكن ما تحقش انكماش ولكن في
نفس الوقت على الورق ان انت يعني بقت زي
ما كنت السنه اللي فاتت وعندك تعداد سكان
كبير جدا عندك اصلا ظروف صعبه ما هو الشخص
السري اللي ما بيقدرش يكسب السنه دي او
حتى ما حصلش على مرتبه الشهر ده ما عندوش
مشكله ممكن يصبر شهر شهرين لكن في دول
فقيره ما عندهاش ريسيشن بمعنى ان حققت
محقق ما تراجعش النمو او حقق النمو صغير
لكن في النهايه هي فقيره جدا في حاجه
لمعدلات نمو عاليه هيبقى يكون على الورق
ما فيش ريسيشن انما المعاناه كبيره وقالت
عشان ما اخرجش بره سؤالك ان النمو سوف
يطال الاقتصادات الثلاثه الكبيره اللي هي
الصين والاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات
المتحده وبالتالي همم اكيد يعني هي
المشكله بقى مش من السنه دي كويسه ولا
وحشه المشكله قد ايه المساله سوف تظل
موجوده في اوروبا
وعلى ال يعني على مستوى العالم كله دي
مساله عاوزه مناقشه يعني
اعتقد هتيجي في وسط الاسئله مساء الخير يا
امير ربنا يخليك ممدوح ما هي اسباب العداء
التاريخي بين القرد والترك
العداء التاريخي يعني قصه طويله انما انت
لك ان تتخيل كالاتي منطقه كردستان الكبرى
ومحتاج تعمل جوجل يجعلها كردستان الكبرى
اللي هي الموطن التاريخي للقرد
هي عباره عن منطقه جزء منها موجود في
ايران جزء منها موجود في سوريا جزء منها
موجود في العراق جزء منها موجود في ايران
في تركيا
بعد نهايه الحرب العالميه الاولى بدات في
حركه بعد هزيمه الامبراطوريه التركيه وثم
بالتدريج خروج
القوى الاوروبيه اللي حلت محلها في
السنوات اللاحقه في الدول كثيره ابتدت
تسعه للحصول على استقلالها
في ناس نجحت زي الدول العربيه اللي حصلت
والكرد والكرد على وجه التحديد فشله فشله
لانه كانت مشكلتهم اعمق بكثير من مثلا
الناس اللي موجودين في جنوب السودان ان هم
ينفصلوا عن تيمور الشرقيه اللي ما اللي
موجوده مثلا في
اندونيسيا الجزيره صغيره حوالي اظن يعني
بضعه ملايين قليله لانه هيستقله عن مين
هيستقلوا عن تركيا ولا عن ايران ولا عن
سوريا ولا عن العراق
يعني طموحهم في ان كل يوم دوله لو كانوا
يحصلوا على دوله كانوا حصلوا عليها من 100
سنه فاتت ردا على سؤالك في اعداد ضخمه
الرقم مش مش حاضر في ذهني في تركيا من
الكورد بعضهم كان عنده طموحات انفصاليه
وقد هذا الطموح الانفصالح حزب العمال
الكردستاني وزعيمه عبد الله وجولان اللي
هو موجود في السجن
بديل ان كل حكومه كانت بتضرب هذا الحزب
وتحديدا من سنه 84 83 لما ابتدا يدخل في
صدام مع الدوله تبقى في عمليه صراع مسلح
تركيا ادركت انه مش كفايه ان انا اضرب
طموحات حزب العمال الكردستاني داخل حدودي
لانه لو هو نجح في انه لو اي كوردي نجح في
انه يقيم دوله في الثلاث دول الاخرى
هتنتقل العدوى اوتوماتيك الى حدودي
وبالتالي بدات تتعاون مع الدول الاخرى
لضرب القرب في في الدول الاخرى يعني
السوريين مع الايرانيين مع العراقيين
تكاتفوا بدرجات مختلفه على ضربه طموحات
الاكراد لكن مؤخرا ااه كانت تركيا
لانه عشان نقول ليه لازم نعرف موقف ايران
لازم نعرف موقف العراق لازم نعرف سوريا
ايران ترفض سوريا ترفض ان تقوم دوله كرديه
على حدودها العراق بسبب ظروف الاحتلال
والتفتيت نجحوا في ان هم يحصلوا على اللي
هو الحكم الذاتي
شيء صعب كانت تقبل به العراق في او بقوتها
واذكر كويس جدا انه همم
[موسيقى]
الرئيس صدام الحسن كان الرئيس صدام كان
دائما يقول لهم همم يعني ليس لكم من
كردستان الا حق البكاء عليها يعني انتم
تعيطوا عليها انما تطالبوا بيها وتحظوا
بحكم ذاتي لا يمكن ابدا وبالتالي دائما
الاتراك الامين من ان اي يا جماعه كرديه
همم يمكن ان تحصل على اي حكم ذاته او
استقلال وبعضهم بيذهب في ذلك بشكل متطرف
ويقول لو اقام القرد خيمه في دوله افريقيا
لسعين لهدمها
ايه
يسعد مساك ده يا يزن
دي يزن حابب اعرف نظرتك لمعاهده لوزان من
من تجديد معادله الاوزان واحده من
المعاهدات اللي شكلت حدود
تركيا بعد الحرب العالميه الاولى ما هي
تركيا كانت الامبراطوريه العثمانيه
لما هزمت بدات تجبر على التنازل عن
مستعمراتها السابقه
وبقت هي محصوره في شبه جزيره الاناضول
اللي احنا شايفنها دي
فمعاهده لوزان رسمت الحدود الحديثه
التركيه ايه قصه لوزان اللي هي المفروض
هيعدي عليها ذكرى مئه عام في هذا العام
المعاهدات بعد 100 عام في قناعه وانا مش
متخصص في القانون الدولي بيقولوا انه يمكن
ان نقوس عن المعاهدات بعد المضيئه مائه
عام عليها انا اشك في ان ده ينطبق على
الحدود
بس اشك ما اشكش القصه هنا محتاجه اسئله
محدده
للمتخصصين بس حتى لو المتخصصين قالوا يجوز
الكلام ده هيمشي زي منطقيا انه كل دوله
رسمت حدودها بعد 100 سنه تقول انا لن
التزم بهذا الاتفاقيه يعني معنى كده ايه
ان ما عادش في حدود لتركيا معنى كده ان هي
بتقول له كل الدول اللي حواليها انا في
حاله صراع معكم اما ان اوسع حدودي على
حسابكم او اقصر وتوسعوا حدودكم على حسابي
فده يعني كلام مش منطقي ده كلام بيتم
الترويج لهم من يعني عفوا من جانب همم ناس
مش عارفه بصراحه يعني سامحوني يعني واذكر
كويس جدا انه من حوالي ثلاث اربع سنين كان
في موجه كده من الارض غنيين العرب اللي هم
العرب اللي مصالحهم مرتبط باردوغان وخاصه
من التيار الاسلامي انه كان بيقولوا انه
هو اللي
مكمل اردوغان عن تحقيق نهضه اكبر بكثير هي
اتفاقيه الاوزان وسوف تنتهي وده حلو يعني
امور كثيره جدا وفقا وبعضهم قال في بنود
سريه كمان تسمح بانهاء هذه الاتفاقيه لا
يوجد هذا الكلام لا في اتفاق سري ولا غير
سري ولو كان في اتفاقيه السريه كانت عرفت
خلال التسعه ال 100 سنه بقى مش 99 سنه
اللي فاتت على كل الاحوال لا يمنع ابدا
اذا اردتم ان احنا نطرحها بالتفصيل
انا كنت بسال بعض الاكاديميه الكبار
والمؤرخين الاتراك يعني لما بتجمعنى فرصه
اليوم فكانوا بيسخروا من هذا الكلام يعني
سعيد باشعارك اللايف ربنا يخليك ويحفظك
والله
هل سينجح لو في حد انا اتشرف ان انا اقول
اساميكم بشكل مباشر بس لا الرجاء تكتبوها
بالعربي لان الاسماء الحرجيه بتبقى صعب
يعني في نقطها
هل سينجح الاتفاق الطاري الايطالي في
السودان في ظل الحرب
والله لا اعلم
يعني قد تصب كل الاطراف بالاجهاد بس علشان
اقول لك ان هي ممكن وممكن جدا لازم تكون
في اراده دوليه والعالم الحقيقه مش حاطط
السودان في اولوياته انا اسف يعني وده
اللي بيخليني مش متفائل لان السودانيين
يعني متروكين لحالهم وما فيش دوله في ظروف
السوداني يمكن ان تحل مشاكلها بدون اراده
دوليه اوعي تصدقوا كلمه هذا شان سوداني
ولا لا يسمح بالتدخل الخارجي ده كلام
انشائي كل الدول بتتدخل فيه شؤون كل الدول
واحيانا التدخل ده بيكون طبعا سلبي
واحيانا بيكون له جوانب ايجابيه انه
بيساعد الدوله المازومه ان تحل لمشاكلها
مساء الخير سيد اردوغان خسر اسطنبول
وانقره مضبوط في انتخابات البلديه 2019
بسبب العلويين
يعني الفئه العلويه مشكلون 30% من الشعب
التركي
وهذا مؤشر قوي على احتمالات خساره
انتخابات 2023 لذلك لجا للاسد كونه مؤثر
انا ما عنديش المعلومه دي وما عنديش نسبه
مشاركه العلويين وتاثيرهم لكن فكره خسارته
للانتخابات همم ممكن ورده مانع هو عموما
الراجل بقى حوالي 20 سنه في السلطه دايما
في تعبير كده ان الناس
السياسي اييي بيخسر لما اوفر ستايز ولكم
يعني انه يتجاوز
يتجاوز بقائه في السلطه اكثر من قدره
الناس على تقبله حتى لو كان عمل انجازات
بيجي بعد فتره يقولوا له كفايه البقاء في
السلطه عمل متعب جدا ولما تبقى خمس سنين
10 سنين 12 سنه يكفي جدا يعني لو كنت انت
عظيم فقد قدمت كل ما لديك واذا كنت انت مش
موفق فيك
الكلام ده بيخصش اردوغان ده يخص كل الناس
في السلطه ولذلك الدساتير الكبيره
المستقره بتقول للناس اربع خمس سنين ويجدد
معظم الدول اللي هي متقدمه جدا بيكفي في
فترتين ثلاثه كفايه
[موسيقى]
استاذ الدكتور احمد يوسف احمد ابدى ملحوظه
يعني كم سنه وانا بكلمه عن ثورات الربيع
العربي قال لي يبدو ان المزاج العربي
والشرق اوسطي عند في حدود ال 30 سنه 25
سنه ههه 29 اسف 29 سنه 30 سنه لانه لاحظ
لانه زين العابدين الرئيس اليمني همم
الرئيس المصري اللي هو مبارك همم
همم الرئيس السوداني عمر حسن البشير وصلوا
الى مستوى ال 30 ثم انقلبت الشعوب عليهم
يعني
معنى كده ان وفقا لهذه القصه انه يمكن
للرئيس التركي بس تركيا اكثر انضباطا مننا
رغم التجاوز في
مسائل الانتقال السلطه لكن اكثر تنظيما من
الدول العربيه في وضع افضل ما هو افضل ما
رايك بالاقتصاد الجزائري الاقتصاد
الجزائري اقتصاد مغلق يعني عشان تقول رايي
هو طبعا بلد غني عنده ثروات كبيره وعنده
عدد سكان معقول وعنده موقع ممتاز وعنده
حاجات كثيره وعنده وسائل تاثير لكن هو
اقتصاد مغلق الى حد كبير انت عارف سوء
المال لل- اوضاع سوء المال في
الجزائر انت عارف يعني المشاكل السياسيه
والاستغنيشن او الركود السياسي اللي ضل
صلوات قليله همم مع الرئيس رحمه الله ال-
همم الرئيس عبد العزيز
بسبب مرضه فيعني الاقتصاد الجزائري ااا
اقتصاد غني وجيد انما الاجماع يعني انه
يمكن ان يكون افضل من ذلك بكثير وربما
تكون هناك ده بصفه عامه التطورات الخاصه
الحقيقه محتاجه الاجابه يعني تدقيق اكثر
وهذا لم يتسنى ليه في الفتره الاخيره يعني
ما هو افضل وقت الاستثمار العقاري في
الشهور المقبله لست خبيرا عقار عقاريا يا
حسين ولكن في حلقه احنا عملناها ما
بتتكلمش على العقار بتتكلم على كل فرص
الاستثمار
والحلقه موجوده على نعرف اقتصاد
والحلقه دي بتتكلم على افضل فرس الاستثمار
في 23 والفكره اللي فيها انه عام 23 سوف
يكون عمرو كود وبالتالي الاسد كلها الاصول
بتهبط الى اقل من المستويات اللي كانت
عليها في 22 و21 و16 وما دام السلع طهبط
اسعارها بيكون دي فرصه جيده لمن يملك
المال سلعه كانت قيمتها 100 هبطت الى 70
وانت فاهم في السلعه وعارف ان دي قيمه
كويسه انت بتروح وتشتريها وعلشان كده
الناس بيتجاوز الركود الاسعار كلها بتنزل
لمستويات كبيره اللي معه فلوس بيدخل يشتري
وهكذا وهكذا فتبتدي الاسعار تعود تبقى
السوق مستقر ثم تسخن تسخن يعني اتجاه
اوفرتيت يحصل تضخم التضخم ده يحتاج معالجه
وهكذا يعني ننتقل من الركود العكس تماما
اللي هو التضخم بتبقى دورات اقتصاديا
الاجابه المختصره انا لا افهم
في سوق العقار انا باتكلم في كلام عام ثم
ان سوء العقار لو عاوز توجه السؤال لازم
تسال همم الخبير للعقاري ده ولا وتتاكد من
حاجتين انا وليس مستفيدا يعني هيستفيد
ازاي ما هو انت لما بتسال اللي بيبنه
العقارات هيقول لك لازم تشتري لما تسال
الناس اللي عنهمش مصلحه في العقار وليه
مصلحه في امور اخرى قد يصرفك فتتاكد ان هو
ليس له مصلحه في انه كل الناس
عاوزه تشتري عقارات وخلاص دائما اصحاب
الشركات العقاريه بيقولوا كده وت- وتحدد
لي السؤال انت بتسال على العقارات في اي
مدينه في اي منطقه اي فئه اقتصادي اجتماعي
يعني رخيص يعني ولا متوسط فاخر
مساء الخير جميعا سالم الله يخليك
الانضمام كرواتيا للاتحاد الاوروبي
الاوروبي دليل على قوه الاتحاد هو يعني
كرواتيا بلدي يعني ما هياش ااا ما هياش
المانيا واكيد هتحصل على مزايا من الاتحاد
طبعا ما هو الاتحاد ما هو الاوروبي قوي
يعني قوي بمعنى ايه بمعنى انه انت اذا كنت
دوله صغيره وانضميت الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
اوضاعك يمكن ان تكون افضل مما لو تركت
وحدك في هذا العالم الموحش
كرواتيا مش بريطانيا وعموما بريطانيا لما
خرجت من الاتحاد الاوروبي كان ده واحد من
الاسباب الرئيسيه لتراجع اقتصادها ما
دلاله حديث تبول عن وجود فاجنر في مالي ما
دلاله حديث تبول ما هو
بقطع النظر عن
يعني
لو بتسال على ان هو ليه بيلمح ولا بتسال
ان هم موجودين في مالي ولا لا وجودهم في
مالي ده محل حديث الكل يعني الفرنسيين
بيتكلموا الالمان بيتكلموا الامريكان
بيتكلموا همم اما اذا كنت تقصد بقى ايه
اللي قاله يعني يعني هو يعني يقصد ايه
تحديدا انا لم اقرا التصريح فلو كتبت لي
التصريح ممكن او انا اراجعه لما ارجع بس
تقول لي يعني تحدد السؤال بعد اذنك
منور ربنا يخليك نادين هل تشعل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده حربا مع غزه ده قولا
واحدا
اذا لم تشعل حروب اخرى هذه حكومه بالغه
التطرف على مستويات المستوى القومي وعلى
المستوى الديني وهي مجموعه من السياسيين
المتطرفين باي معيار مش بمعيارنا احنا
كعرب او او في المنطقه الشرق اوسطيه
والعالم الاسلامي ده هي متطرفه بمعيار
الاسرائيليين وبمعيار الاداره الامريكيه
هذه اول مره على هذا النحو اشوف الحكومه
الامريكيه
بتتحفظ وتهدد بانها لن تتعاون مع الحكومه
اذا جاء فيها كذا وكذا وجاءت الحكومه
ودلوقتي التصريحات الامريكيه بتصف بعض
تصرفات المنتسبين اليها بانها يعني همم
مثيره للنفور اا زي ال- طبعا السيد غفير
بن غفير اللي هو بقى
وزير الامن القومي اللي مسؤول عن همم
والحرس الحرس الحدود
ده راجل بلغ الخطوره يعني
هل ترى يا استاذ ده وضع الاخلاق للكورونا
ممكن ينعاد في العالم مما يجري في الصين
والله اذا حصلت طبعا السؤال احنا ما كناش
نتوقع ان ده هيحصل فيه سنه 20
والحقيقه انه همم اذا الفيروس تحور
فملمان يعني بس انا اسمح لي اوسع لك
السؤال واقول لك في حلقه بعنوان التحديات
الاربعه اللي بتهدد العالم ليه العالم
بيعيش في اضطرابات دي معموله من فتره
صغيره جدا وانا باعد للحلقه دي وباتكلم مع
بعض المصادر احد من اساتذه الفيروسات قال
لي انه
المساله مش همم يعني انه قاصره على فيروس
كرونه او متحوراته
احنا بنعيش هجمات فيروسيه متلاحقه من اكثر
من 35 40 سنه من اول فيروس الايدز وبعد
كده بقى المتحورات المختلفه
ليه يعني او الفيروسات الاخرى اللي جاي
يلتهم دلوقتي طبعا اللي هي الفيروس اللي
تسبب انفلونزا الخنازير وانفلونزا الطيور
واثار
ومتلازمه الشرق الاوسط
وكرونا الى اخره مجموعه من الفيروسات
الكثيره اللي بتجيء للناس اللي بتهاجم
البشر على مدار 35 40 سنه
وجهه نظر هذا العالم انه المساله المرتبطه
بالتغير المناخي اللي ادى الاضطرابات في
البيئه الطبيعيه للحشرات والحيوانات واا
القوارض الى اخره وبالتالي تصاب بامراض
بتمرض ليه لان البيئه الطبيعيه بتاعتها
بقت مهدده بتعيش في بيئه طبيعيه مختلفه
درجه الحراره ارتفعت درجه الحراره انخفضت
الغابه اللي كانت فيها تم ازالتها الى
اخره البحر اصبحت ملوحته درجته الى اخره
تغيرت الامراض دي بقت تنتقل من هات
والطيور الى الانسان
وده اللي حصل على الاقل احد النظريات
الانتقال فيروس كورونا وبالتالي المساله
لن تقتصر للاسف على كرونا وبيتوقعوا ان في
هجوم فيروسات اخرى حد ثاني كنت قريت له
مقال في مجله علميه محترمه بيقول انه
التغير المناخي وذوبان الجليد في القطب
الشمالي على وجه التحديد معناه ان كل
الفيروسات اللي محبوسه تحت سطح هذه
الشريحه اللي كانت سميكه جدا امطار في
القطب الشمالي كانت مختبئه من يعني الاف
السنين هذه الفيروسات مع ذوبان الجليد
يمكن ان تعود لتطارد البشريه مره اخرى
ونسال الله اللطف
انما اللي ممكن تراقبه على المدى القريب
كده هي الوضع في الصين الصين
نسب الاصابه بتزيد فيها واضح ان ده اذا
استمروا عجزت عن السيطره عليه ده معناها
ان هيبقى في مشاكل في الاقتصاد الصيني
واذا كان في مشاكل في الاقتصاد الصيني ده
ممكن ياثر على اقتصادات العالم كلها
صندوق النقد الدولي او رئيس ستو كانت
بتصفه ببش فاير عامل زي كانك ولعت في همم
غابه كده فبتنتقل من شجره الشجره ده في
الاقتصاد الصيني واذا حصل كده هيبقى هذا
الاشتعال هينتقل من الصين الى الدول
الاخرى
ربنا يخليك يا طارق اشكرك يقال ان اقتصاد
الصين
مبالغ فيه جدا
ما يقارب النصف هل معقول ان هذا صحيح انا
لم افهم السؤال الاخير اذا كنت تقصد
يعني
يعني ايه في الجلد بي ولا تقصد ايه انا مش
عارف اكبر ازمه كما راها كما اراها في
ازمه الثقه في الحكومه مما يزيل الطين عن
اي حكومه يا محمد معظم الشعباء معظم
الشعوب لا تثق في حكمتها فلو انت تقصد
حكومه معينه قل لي
لماذا فشل المشروع القومي العربي
سؤال كبير عادل ما هو المشروع فشل لان
يعني انت بتتكلم على مشروع جمال عبد
الناصر في الخمسينات وبعدين حزب البعث
اللي موجود في العراق وسوريا والاحزاب
الناصريه والاحزاب كل دول كان عندهم تصور
يعني الحقيقه يعني
مبني على فكره انه العرب يتحدوا انه اتحاد
العرب اتحاد العرب ده اتحاد اي مجموعه من
الدول مساله عصيره يعني احنا مساله عسيره
احنا تربينا على ان العرب فاشلين وان
العرب همم دائما اتفقوا على ان يختلفوا
الحقيقه ان الكلام ده بعد فتره من الدراسه
والتاني في كثير من المبالغه وفي كتير من
الطول من العرب ايوه العرب
فشلوا في مساله الاتحاد بس الحقيقه مش هم
بس يعني دول الاتحاد الاوروبي عاشوا مئات
السنين بل الاف السنين في حاله حرب ثم
تالفه مؤخرا في اتحاد اوروبي خطواته بطيئه
جدا جدا جدا وهو الان مهدد بالتفتت
الامثله كثيره يعني يعني الاتحاد الامريكي
ده اتبنى عبر اا يعني تجارب الاول اتبنت
على انه الناس لها مصلحه ان هي تروح
شايفين ان مصلحتهم في الاتحاد الامريكي
لكن برده ده من خلاش من استخدام القوه
للابقاء عليه في
1861 اللي هي الحرب الاهليه الامريكيه
اللي استمرت ثلاث اربع سنين
فالعرب يعني مش
احنا كمان بنقارن العرب بالدول الاوروبيه
والمتقدمه اللي تجربتهم نضجت على مدار
سنين كثيره جدا جدا جدا جدا كل اللي حصل
عندنا حصل عند الغربيين وائل
واليابانيين وغيرهم من الدول المتقدمه هم
بداوا التجربه بدري على العموم ردا على
سؤال حضرتك
العرب عندهم مشكلات عديده جدا جدا جدا
منها انه انت لازم تبدا الاول بتعاون
اقتصادي والتعاون الاقتصادي ده بيقوم على
اسس منها اللي يكون فيه بيناتكم لو كلنا
بنبيع مواد خامه بيتهيا لي فكره التكامل
والمعاش فكره عظيمه
ثم بقى مشاكل اقتصاديه مختلئ مشاكل سياسيه
مختلفه زراعه اسرائيل في المنطقه كان عامل
مؤثر جدا مش كل منطقه في العالم عندها
اسرائيل
ويعني هذا الموضوع يستحق ان احنا ممكن
ناخشه في اوقات اخرى هل سيتفكك الاتحاد
الاوروبي قريبا لا اعتقد انه ممكن يتفقد
قريبا لكن فكره تفككه مطروحه كل يوم
ودائما موجوده على المائده انه احتمال
وارد
هل تصبح سلبيه والكسوف هو روسيا اوكرانيا
الجديده ممكن جدا تشتعل الحرب بين صربيا
وكسوفه ممكن جدا
لماذا يترك اردوغان رغم توجهه هي ما
اعترفتش اصلا مش عاوزه تعترف باستقلال
يعني صربيا لا تعتقد ان كسوف تستحق
الاستقلال كدوله يعني
وده اللي مخلي الكوسوفي الى حد كبير يعني
بتحضر بتسعى لدعم من اسرائيل والولايات
المتحده وطبعا صربيا بتحضر بدعم تقليدي من
روسيا لماذا يترك اردوغان رغم توجهه
الاسلامي الواضح
اترك ايه بقى
انت ما قولتش
هل يوجد امل في اقتصاد مصر وهل هناك دوله
تعرض سعر فائده 25 في المئه
اه يعني فيه بتقول لي في امل في امل هل
الاقتصاد يمر بحاله صعبه بيمر بحاله صعبه
جدا هل الازمه الاقتصاديه في مصر عاديه لا
هي ازمه يعني من الدول اللي بتعاني من
ازمات شديده
يعني هل الحل وشيك وانه الامور سوف تعود
همم وتبقى الامور جيده لغلاء سوف يظل
لفتره طويله فرص الحل هتحتاج الى وقت طويل
ان بدات الحكومه بشكل جيد ال- ال- ال- ال-
وضع يعني ما في شك انه صعب بس يعني لو انت
عاوز دائما لما بنتكلم على الاقتصاد
المصري انا ملاحظ ان ما حدش عاوز يعرف
اجابه بصراحه يعني دائما لما باسمع
الاجابات بلاقي ان الناس اسمه مقسمين اصلا
بحيث انه الاجابه دائما بتكون مسيسه ما
فيش من النادر انك تلاقي احد عاوز يدي
اجابه مهنيه او اجابه صادقه بلا غلط عاده
اللي بيخلي الوضع وردي هو من المؤيدين
للرئيس السيسي هي العمليه منقسمه حوالين
الرئيس السيسي زي ما الاسرائيليين على
شخصيه واحده نتنياهو المصريين منقسمين على
شخصيه واحده او المصريين
اللي هم مؤ ومريديه دائما خصوصا اذا ذكروا
من المتحدثين والنخب اللي هي اكثر همم
عاده اللي دائما ممكن تستفيد بشكل مباشر
من المديح يعني هي اللي دائما بتخلي
الصوره ورديه اكثر مما ينبغي فبتخلي الناس
تفقد الثقه في اللي هم بيقولوه والناس
المعارضين وخصوصا اللي في الخارج او الناس
اللي هم ظروفهم صعبه جدا ومش مدارين
الحقيقه احيانا
بيناقشوا بيحاولوا يسووا الوضع الاقتصادي
حتى لو كانت في جوانب ايجابيه فقط لان هم
عندهم موقف من الرئيس يعني انما لو بنتكلم
بمهنيه عادي بشكل جيد لاقتصاد المصري
يعاني من مشكله كبيره فعلا ده واحد لكنه
ليس الاقتصاد الوحيد الذي يعاني والحاجه
الوحيده اللي بتشفع لهذه الحكومه او شيء
اساسي على هذه الحكومه ان هي لما تقول لست
وحدي فهي صادقه
اوضاع صعبه حتى في الاقتصادات الكبيره
انما
وفي الاقتصادات
انما طبعا ده ما يمنعش انه كل واحد بيكون
قلقان على بلده وبيراقب الوضع بيقول
الظروف الاقتصاديه الان صعبه وكانت بالامس
صعبه وهي على الارجح سوف تظل صعبه امتى
مصر كدوله اقليميه عندها امكانيات جيده
تبقى مستقره اقتصاديه ده السؤال اللي
دائما محير كل الناس واللي الناس مش
قادرين يتوافقوا على خطه
لاطلاق الاقتصاد المصري انطلاق الاقتصاد
المصري لن يتحقق بدون توافق سياسي اساسا
ما فيش دوله بتحقق
انتعاش اقتصادي الا لما بتستقر تماما
ويحصل توافق بين النقاب السياسيه على افضل
طريقه لاستغلال الثروات البلد ولكن يبدو
انه الاوضاع في الوقت الحالي سوف تظل
اوضاع همم
يعني اوضاع صعبه يعني ليه شهور انما ارجع
لحضرتك بتقول لي في امل ايوه في امل ان
انا دائما لما بقول الناس اللي بيتكلموا
على انه البلد هي انهار مش عارف خلال ايه
وقفلاس انا استبعد هذا الكلام اظن ان
الظروف سوف تظل صعبه لكنها ليست بالغه
الخطوره
بلغت الخطوره انا بتكلم على مستقبل البلد
يعني مش بنتكلم احنا على السريلانكا ولا
على لبنان ولا على غانا ولا الكلام ده لكن
بنتكلم على بلد عنده مشاكل اقتصاديه صعبه
مساء الخير يا ربنا يخليك الله يخليك يا
محمد هلال شكرا جزيلا على الكلام الطيب هل
تتوقع ان ما يحدث في الاردن من احداث خلال
الشهر الفائت له علاقه بصعود نتنياه للحكم
في حكومه متطرفه وهل له ثار مع العاهل
السعودي الاردني الاردن دايما العيش على
صفيح ساخن ما اقدرش اكزم يعني الاردنيين
ما قالوش ان ده له علاقه بس الاردن
انا مره كتبت كنت عملت حلقه عن الاردن من
فتره يمكن سنتين ولا حاجه
ولاحظت وانا بعمل بحث والاعداد للحلقات
احيانا بياخذ اسابيع وربما احيانا شهور
لغايه ما الاقيش اجابه فاقفل الملف وارجع
له ان الاردن من بين الدول اللي عندها
حاجه غريبه كده ابحث اعمل سيرش في بس يكون
مثلا باللغه الانجليزيه
ليه لان المحتوى في اللغه الانجليزيه كثير
دائما في كل تقريبا فتره هتبحث عنها تجد
انه المقالات مكتوبه انه الاردن على وشك
الانهار
الاردن بلد ظروفه صعبه جدا ويعيش
بعد رحمه الله بفضل المهاره في محاوله انه
يلتقطه الكره عارف اللي هو اللي في السيرك
ده عاوزه براعه لانه هو على المستوى
الاقتصادي بلد يعني محدود الموارد
ويجاور دوله عدو
الدوله العدو دي كانت سبب الرئيسي في
تهجير عدد كبير من الفلسطينيين من غرب
الاردن لشرق الاردن وبالتالي هو يعني
دائما عاوز يرضي شريحه كبيره جدا من
الشارع لا يستطيع اغضبها ولازم يتخذ مواقف
متشدده من السياسات الاسرائيليه
خصوصا بان كمان هو مسؤول او راعي او يعني
الكاسترين للاماكن المقدسه الاسلاميه
الاماكن المقدسه كلها يعني ففي برده راي
عام اسلامي ضغط عليه وهو ما يقدرش يبالغ
في عداء الاسرائيليين لان اسرائيل ما فيش
وجه للمقارنه بين موازين القوه فدائما
ظروف الاردن صعبه
وتزداد الصعوبه في اوقات الازمات
الاقتصاديه الاردن بدون مساعدات ملحها
ومستمره دائما بيواجه ازمات
بس من حسن حظي الاردنيين عندهم مستوى
تعليم جيد الحقيقه يعني افضل من المتوسط
مستوى التعليم في دول اخرى كثيره اكثر
استقرارا منه
اهم سؤال هنعمل ايه في فلوسنا اللي في
البنوك وقيمتها بتقل
يعني انت بتتكلم على ايه كلمه من اللهجه
كده واضح انت مصري يعني اذا كان عندك فرصه
يعني انت تستمر اموالك في شيء بتفهم في
اهلا وسهلا اذا ما كانش عندك
هيكون افضل حاجه تعملها انا مش عارف فلوسك
قد ايه ولكن بتلاقي نفسك
استاذ مصري
كان عايش طول عمره بره
مصر اظن في 2020 وبعدين سالني سؤال غريب
جدا يعني سؤال بالنسبه له هو بدا غريب
يقول لي ليه المصريين بيجروا على البنوك
لما كانت الفائده حوالي 20% وحاطين صفوف
طويله جدا ويحطه فلوسهم في الجروب
قال لي بس كده الفائده سالب يعني كانت
تضخم 27 ولا 25 كده هو خسران 5% هو يجري
على البنك لو ان هي الفائده حقيقيه يعني
التضخم مثلا 20
تضخم مثلا ساعتها كان 18 ولا 15 والفائده
20 فجر انما هو بيحط فلوسه في البنك على
20 والتضخم 27 فالتاكل بيتم 7% مثلا
فقلت له لانه فرص الاستثمار مش زي اوروبا
اللي انت كنت عايش فيها ان في فرصه
استثمار اخرى افضل من ايداع الاموال في
البنوك فرد على سؤالك لو عندك قدره انك
تقدر توظف اموالك القليله في بشكل امن
اهلا وسهلا لو ما عندكش هتضطر تكتفي بانك
انت
بتقلل من فرص تراجع ال- اا
او تاكل الاموال اذا ما حطيتش حطيتهاش في
الجهاز المصرفي
لو عندك رغبه للمخاطره قليلا تحط جزء في
البنوك وجزء بقى انت تشوف كده يعني فرص
الاستثمار في الاوراق الماليه
لو عندك شهيه بس تبقى بكميات صغيره جدا
برايك ما هي اليه الحل في سوريا لا ما فيش
حل سهل في سوريا ابدا لانه الحل في سوريا
مرتبط بمصالح الدول الكبيره اقليميه
ودوليه وهذه الدول حتى الان غير متوافقه
استاذنا الفاضل هل ترى ان فرجك قريبا
للازمه اليمنيه لا مش شايف انفراج قريبه
للاسئله اليمنيه شايف ان هي تحولت من صراع
حامي جدا يعني كل الاطراف بتضرب بعض
بالمدافع والدبابات الى صراع منخفض
الكثافه يعني في طرف زي ما ح- مثلا حزب
الله كده جاء في فتره لما كان مثلا 2006
و2008 في حاله احتقان انما في طرف مسيطر
فالاطراف في اليمن كلها الباقيه باستثناء
ال يعني انصار الله ايه الطرف الاقوى
عسكريه في قوته مخليه الاطراف الاخرى غير
راغبه في ان هي تبدا صراحه يعني صراع
منخفض الكثافه وبس السؤال هل ممكن انصار
الله او الحوثيين يقدروا يستمروا رغم
الازمه الاقتصاديه العنيفه جدا جدا جدا ده
مساله هتتوقف على قدرتهم على اداره
الاقتصاد في ظل ظروف صعبه
ولا ايه رايك كمان ده اكيد طبعا اكيد
طبعا ايه اللي بيحصل في مصر
والاقتصاد المهلهل والقرارات
الغريبه من الحكومه والبنك المركزي على
فكره في حلقه قبل ما ادخل على طول هي ما
فيش قرارات غريبه ولا حاجه هي يعني هي
الوضع في حلقه انا قبل ما ادخل النهارده
لانه كاتب ظروف ما تسمحش بحلقه يعني لان
البنك المركزي النهارده او البنوك
النهارده فعلت عمليه زياده الفائده واصدرت
فوائد بنسبه 25% لو انت هتاخذ العائد على
مدار سنه يعني انت حطيت 100,000 جنيه
النهارده في البنك الاهلي او البنك المصري
تاخدهم ال 100,000 جنيه + 25,000 في همم
يناير 2024
واذا اخذت العائد مش بشكل سنوي اخذت نفس
العائد بس على اساس شهري هتاخذ عائد نسبته
22.5% ثم ابتدا الجنيه يتحرك هبوطا من 24
و60 مثلا الى 26 و20 قرش حاجه زي كده اهو
ده كان كلها حاجات متوقعه لانه هو عنده
ازمه مش هيعرف يخرج منها غير بالطريقه دي
وتوقعه التالي زياده في اسعار المحروقات
زياده في اسعار الكهرباء همم
توقعوا عمليه خصخصه او بيع لمستثمرين
اجانب ليه بعض الاصول المصريه دي كلها
حاجات معينه يعني همم انما عموما في حلقه
عملتها مع صديقنا هاني عشان نعلق بسرعه
موجوده دلوقت على نعرف اقتصاد معموله
بالزوم ممكن تشوفه فيها تعليق اوسع ليه
الاحداثي يعني الحاجه اللي انا ما قلتهاش
في الحلقه بس اللي انا قلتها في الحلقه
الثانيه
وان شاء الله تيجي في حلقات انه لما بنعرف
هذا النوع من الحلول وبنقول انها حلول
جيده من البنك المركزي او وزاره الماليه
المصريه في ظل الاطار اللي احنا بنتكلم
فيه يعني ان دي كحلول لتخفيف الازمه
العنيفه دلوقت البلد ما فيش فيها دولار
البلد محتاجه تحصل على همم قروض وهكذا
بتجيء لي دائما اسئله يعني هي القروض هي
الحل لا انا ما قلتش كده دائما الحل كل
الناس عارفه ان الحل هو ان انت يبقى عندك
اقتصاد صحيح وانتاجي لكن ده على المدن
بعيد انت عندك واحد صحته معتله
ما تقدرش تقول له شارك في الاولمبيات او
اجري رياضه كل يوم فانت بتقول له التزم
الاول بالادويه
واحيانا ان انت تحصل على قرض احيانا بيكون
ميزه كبيره ما تونس مش عارفه يعني تونس
اوضاعها سيئه لكن هم عاجزين عن اقناع
صندوق النقد الدولي الى الناس او شريحه في
مصر بتنتقدوا تونس مش قادره اصلا تحصل او
تقنع الصندوق بان هو يقرضها السودان ظل
لسنوات وما ظل يحلم بانه في احد يقرضه
فاحنا بنتكلم لما بيكون الوضع سيء لازم
الاول تخرج منه وبعد كده ده بقى هو
المطلوب انه لما تستقر الاوضاع زي ما هي
استقرت بعد 2016 انه كان على الحكومه ان
هي تنتهي فرصه 2016 وتعمل تنتقل من
الاصلاحات
الشيء الماليه
والنقديه بينها تعمل بقى اصلاح بجد اللي
هو همم طويل الامل وصعب اللي هو اصلاح
نظام قاضي التامينات الاجتماعيه الضرائب
الى اخره ده هو اللي بياخذ وقت كثير
وللحكومه يعني ما عملتوش بشكل عظيم يعني
همم هل سيتوقف الغرب عن دعم اوكرانيا بسبب
عدم تقدم الاوكران وارد
همم مساء الخير
استاذنا ما هي توقعات ومصير الاقتصاد
السوري في ظل امكانيه حدوث التطبيع مع
التركيه وما هو الحل لتحسن وضع الاقتصاد
السوري المنهار والله يعني انا يعني النوع
ده من الاسئله بيصيبنا باحراج لانه انا
شايف الصوره سيئه جدا فلما بالاقي مثلا في
الغالب بيكون حد من الشباب يعني بيسال
ببراءه هو ممكن الاقتصاد السوري يتحسن
امتى انا الاجابه عندي انه لا يبدو ان
هناك فرص لتحسن ملموس لفتره طويله انت
بتتكلم على انا سمعت يعني من بعض اصدقاء
السوريين انه متوسط دخل ال- ال- الموظفين
في الجهاز الحكومي على الاقل احنا بنتكلم
في حدود همم 25 و30 دولار في الشهر يا ريت
تصلحوا لي المعلومه ديت لو كانت المعلومه
غير دقيقه فالوضع البالغ الدنيا التحتيه
مهدمه ال- الضغوط الامريكيه
رهيبه جدا على الاقل واحد سوريا الدول
الحليفه لسوريا دول بتدعم النظام عشان
يستقر لمصالحها
بس ما عندهاش قدرات ان هي تنعش الاقتصاد
لايران ولا روسيا ولا غيره دول الخليج
مش هتقدر بامانه يعني تدخل سوريا وتستمر
اولا هي عندها بعضهم عنده مشاكل على راسهم
السعوديه بالاضافه انه هتدخلوا في مشاكل
مع الامريكان وهما في غنى عنها خصوصا وان
علاقتهم ببشار الاسد ليست عظيمه
السلام عليكم سؤالي عن التقارير
التي تتحدث عن انهيار الاقتصادات اوروبا
بالاخص المانيا
على المدى القصير والمتوسط هل تراها
منطقيه ام مبالغ فيها كلمه انهيار عمليه
نسبه يعني نتكلم على الاقتصاد الالماني ده
قاعده صناعيه ضخمه جدا واقتصاد
مهول انت بتتكلم في حدود اربعه مليون
دولار مثلا 4 مليون دولار دول قد مره ونص
الاقتصاد في
قد كل منطقه الشرق الاوسط يعني دول يعني
ايران بتركيا بكل الدول العربيه باسرائيل
كمان
فانت بتتكلم على اقتصاد مهول كده بس
الاقتصاد ده دلوقتي
يعني مقدرش يحقق نسب نمو في العام الاخير
وربما تراجع نسبه بسيطه
شويه مع الازمه الطاقه اللي موجوده ديت
كثير من الشركات هتقعد توازن اقعد في
المانيا سواء شركات المانيه وشركات اجنبيه
والشركات الاجنبيه كثيره ولا اروح
لاسواق اكثر استقرارا زي السوق الامريكي
او غيرها يعني اللي هي ما عندهاش مصادر
همم طاقه همم اللي هي عندها مصادر الطاقه
احسن ما عندهاش ازمه طاقه
ثم انه المانيا همم يعني بدات تدخل تجد
انه من الصعب ان هي تعيش زي معاشه زمان
عاشت زمان ازاي ان هي كانت بتعيش على انه
لها حروب بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه وانه
انا مش محتاج اتسلح
وانه همم لو انا لو احتاجت اي تحدي
الاخرين سوف يتكفلوا بها امريكا وفرنسا
وحلف النيته الامور تغيرت وهتبقى في
مخصصات متزايده طبعا للتسليح لكن مش هو ده
ال- اساس يعني لان حتى لو هي فلاحه هي
بتسلح في المصانعها وبالتالي هيبقى جزء من
اقتصادها انما الجزء الاكبر هو الاضطرابات
اللي موجوده في اوروبا واللي يبدو انها لن
تنتهي قريبا حتى لو وضعت الحرب او زارها
في اوكرانيا لان العالم بينقسم زي ما قلت
لحضراتكم الى معسرين واضحين
المانيا المفروض هتبقى مع المعسكر الغربي
والمعسكر الشرقي الصين روسيا والدول
المغضوب عليها امريكا وده يعني تقلص فرص
التجاره ومعناها انه بالنسبه لالمانيا ان
النفط والغاز الرخيص اللي كان يعمل روسيا
قد لا ياتيها على الاقل بنفس المعدلات اه
يعني الاقتصارات دي كلها سوف تتاثر بشكل
كبير مش لازم تنهار يعني وبعدين هما في
الاقتصاد
يعني
ده يعني هو بيقول هو نسبه النمو كذه تراجع
بنسبه ربع نصف واحد كده يعني في ركود
الركود ده لمده ثلاث شهور ست شهور اكتر من
كده يبقى كاسات يعني التعبيرات بتبقى
منظبطه اكثر
السلام عليكم سؤالي عن التقارير التي
تتحدث عن انهيار اخر خلاص
كشخص 17 عام ماذا
اسالك سؤال
يا استاذ سيد قبيل كشخص 17 عام متى تنصحني
لكي ابدا الغوص في عالم السياسه كما لو
كنت ستقدمها لنفسك والله ياوان ارمي ايمان
انا فخور بيك ويا ريت تقول لي اسمك 17 سنه
وقاعد بتسمع هذا الكلام اللي هو يعني
والله انا فخور بيك ربنا يوفقك ويسعدك
وانت عندك 17 سنه عشان تخش على بالسياسه
ابسط حاجه فيها انك تبتدي تقرا كل يوم ولو
ساعه تتخيل انت عندك 17 معنى ذلك لو قرات
ساعه واحده بالاضافه لدراستك اللي انا مش
عارف طبعتها انت في الغالب هتبقى في نهائي
الثانويه العامه في اولى جامعه هفترض ان
انت في نهايه الدراسه الاساسيه بدايه من
الجامعه لو انت بتقرا ساعه بالاضافه
للتخصصك ما انت لو تخصصت في السياسه كل
يوم سياسه يعني
فانت هتعمل 365 ساعه قراءه في السياسه
فانت ده بدايه انك تقرا واستاذنك تقرا لمن
تتفق معه ومن تختلف معه مش لازم تدور على
الحاجه اللي عجباك يعني لو انت مثلا من
المعارضه السوريه ما تدورش على الكتب اللي
بتشتم بشار الاسد او العكس ولكن اقرا شوف
الناس بتقول ايه ده واحد
اثنين لما تقرا تقرا ايه
ولمين
القرايه للعقل زي الاكل للمعده ممكن واحد
بياخذ كل حاجه قدامه وبيحط كميات ممكن
يمرض ممكن يجي له تسمم وفي واحد بينتقي
اكل نظيف كذلك القرايه انت هتقرا ايه اقرا
للعقول الكبيره استمع للعقول الكبيره اللي
انت هتعرفها مع الوقت يعني انا بعد 30 سنه
مثلا لما بكون عاوز ادور على قضيه انا
باروح انا عارف هاروح اقرا لمين وعارف ان
هو هو بيدافع عارف وجهه نظره بغض النظر عن
توجهه انا فاهم التوجه وعارف بس عارف ان
هو شاطر في الحته ديت في الملف ده انت
بتيجي بعد سنين
وبالتالي انت شويه هتنتقد تلاقي مين بيفهم
علشان تروح لعقول كبيره لازم تكون بتعرف
لغه اجنبيه مش لان العقول الكبيره باللغه
العربيه قليله في عقول كبيره لكن دول ما
فيش حريه كبيره لهم ان هم يقولوا ان هم
عاوزينه الا عدد قليل
فهتقرب العربي او باللغه انت بتكتب
بالعربي وتحاول تتعلم لغه اجنبيه
النقطه الاخيره مستحيل تفهم سياسه الا اذا
فهمت جغرافيا لازم تعرف اساسيات جغرافيا
تبتدي تفهم ومش لازم ترجع لكتاب المدرسه
اللي هو بيتكلم على حشائش السفن والعدد
الابقار في المغرب لكن الجغرافيا علم عظيم
جدا لا غنى عنه لازم الاقتصاد اساسيات
الاقتصاد لازم لازم تاخذ فكره عن الافكار
الكبيره اللي شكلت هذا العالم هذا العالم
يحكموه الفلاسفه يعني الناس اللي عملوا
الليبراليه الناس اللي عمله
النظم الاشتراكيه الناس اللي عملوا
الراسماليه الناس دول فلسفه تبتدي تاخذ
فكره عن الفلسفه اللي هي اصحاب العقول
الكبيره وده هيجيء مع القراءه وتحضر على
قد ما تقدر ندوات وتشارك وانا سعيد بسؤالك
والله واتمنى ما اكونش صعدت عليك المهمه
بس انا باقول لك ساعه على الاقل في اليوم
وحاول تبعد شويه عن التلفزيون التلفزيون
للصغيرين والكبار انترتين لكن ما تت- او
تعرف خبر انما لو انت النهارده انا باجرب
انا لا اذكر والله وانا يعني همم من
العواجيز انا لا اذكر ان انا مثلا قعدت
قدام التليفزيون واخذت معلومه ذات اهميه
دائما التليفزيون عنده مشاكل وممكن يجيب
خبر فكره التحليل العميق دي بقت مفتقده في
معظم القنوات لو قناه صغيره ما عندهاش
مصادر لو قناه كبيره بيعمل حاجه غريبه جدا
الشاشه موجوده بيطلع يجي خمس ست همم شرائط
اخبار تتعب العين لازم عدد كثير من الضيوف
فتلاقي عندك ثلاث اربع عيون مع المذيع كل
واحد بياخذ كلمتين ثم فاصل ثم فاصل ما
بتاخذش حاجه وكل قناه عندها توجه فمش ده
اعظم حاجه تاخد منها ولكن القراءه او ان
انت بقى تكون بتتابع مثلا قناه من على همم
اي بودكاست او بودكاست بقت حاجات عظيمه
جدا او لو كان تعرف حد على اليوتيوب ثاني
تسمعه واقتصاد سياسه لانه بيبقى الكلام
خالص ومركز على النقطه اللي انت عاوزها
انا قتلت في الاجابه وانا عارف
وان ار مي مان سلام عليك اكتب لي بقى اسمك
سلام عليك يا استاذ محمد همم
ده محمد خليله
من عرب الداخل اعرب 48 اهلا وسهلا مهما ما
موقف الاداره الامريكيه من الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده لا تحبها لا ترغب
فيها بينهم علاقه متوتره والبشائر سيئه
ولكن وممكن تحصل ازمات مفتوحه حصلت قبل
كده بين الادارات الامريكيه والاسرائيليه
لكن هذه الاداره الاداره الاسرائيليه
الجديده صعب جدا انه الامريكان اما
يصطدموش معها على صعد مختلفه وفي مؤشرات
على التوتر بسبب موقفهم من اوكرانيا
الاسرائيليين عاوزين يلعبوا على كل الحبال
امريكا متوقعه موقف اكثر تضامنا من بنتها
الصغيره في موقف من انه السياسه ديت هتفتح
يعني تشعل المنطقه الامريكان مش عاوزين
حرب في المنطقه فطبعا اي وقت
لماذا الدول الغربيه تفتح باب التجنيس
والضوء لماذا الدول الغربيه تفتح باب
التجنيس والدول العربيه لا تجنس منها عيش
فيها لمده طويله لان في وفره في السكان في
الدول العربيه دول العربيه ما عندهاش
مشاكل سكان انما في مشاكل سكانيه في الدول
المتقدمه بيبحثوا عن هم ناس همم ما عندهمش
معدلات انجاب عاليه وعندهم همم يعني بحكم
ثقافتهم مش عاوزين ينجبوا عاوزين هم
يستمتعوا بحياتهم بعيدا عن الانجاب ف- اا
الدول المتقدمه عندها مشاكل ديموغرافيه
فبترحب بعضها بالسكان خصوصا لو كانوا من
ذوي المؤهلات الجيده يعني انما انت هتجيء
مثلا لدوله زي المغرب وتقول له انا هابعث
لك سكان هل الجزائر محتاجه سكان هل العراق
محتاج سكان هل السودانيين محتاجين سكان هل
بلد زي مصر طبعا ههه مش ممكن ممكن بعد
الدول الخليج بس دول الخليج علشان دول لها
طبيعي خاصه اعداد
قليله والدول الاثريه وتخاف ان هي تتوسع
في مدح الجنسيه فيدوب اهل البلد امام
الهنود والباكستانيين فبيكتفوا بس
بالاقامات الطويله
ايمن بيقول انخفاض سعر الجنيه اليوم تتوقع
تحرير كامل ايوه مش هتوقع ده سياسه معلنه
يا صديقي وشاهد حلقتين على نعرف اقتصاد
ماذا سوف يحدث للاقتصاد المصري في 2023
والحلقه الاخيره اللي عاملينها هاني وانا
همم خلال هذا الاسبوع الحلقه الاخيره
معموله قبل ما اسجل معكم على طول يعني من
ثلاث اربع ساعات
هل تسمحوا لي بس اخذ شويه ماء بعد اذنكم
انخفاض مساء الخير ما هو وضع الساحه
الفلسطينيه في ظل الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الجديده وضع بالغ الصعوبه ودول مجموعه لا
تخفي التطرفها في التوسع في الاستيطان
في ربما يعني طرد بعض
العربي اللي موجودين في الداخل هم قالوا
اظن انه مسافر
[موسيقى]
انا المنطقه يا ريت حد من اصدقائي
الفلسطينيين اللي عايشين في الضفه ويقولوا
لي منطقه مسافر
وطن مسافر منطقه يعني انا قراتها
بالانجليزي وانا اسف هربانه من ذهني ولكن
المنطقه دي اللي الجيش الاسرائيلي كان
بيخطط ليه تهجير اهلها من عشرات السنين
احتمال يهاجروا منها اعطوهم انذار اليوم
الاثنين اللي فات يعني يوم الاثنين ويناير
بتهجير حوالي 1000 فلسطيني منها
فالنواس بالغه السوء من هذه الجماعات
بالغه التطرف
مساء الخير هل ترى الازمات الداخليه في
ايران وتركيا فرصه
لتخفيف الضغط على دول المنطقه ام العكس ده
ممكن يصدروا لنا مشاكلهم اكثر
المشكله مش ان هم يبقى عندهم مشاكل انت
عاوز تقلل مشاكلك لازم انت تقوي قدراتك
الذاتيه
يعني الطبيعي ما بتحبش الفراغ لو ان دوله
قويه واقفه على رجلها خلاص
انما لو دوله ضعيفه اذا قامت مثلا ايران
او تركيا هتتغول عليها واذا ضعفت هتحاول
تصدر لها مشاكلها
مساء الخير برايك هذا الحرب حتميه بين
ارمينيا وادرا بيجان نعم الحرب حتميه لان
الخلافات لم تحسم وصعب جدا ان هي تحسم وكل
ما يتوازن القوى هيميل لصالح ارمينيا همم
اتغير على اذربيجان والعكس صحيح
كيف دا اخونا بندر خالد كيف نظام البنوك
اليابانيه عندما تكون الفائده بالسالب
همم مش فاهم السؤال تقصد انه ازاي بيده هم
البنوك يعني ما هي الفكره في ايه يعني بس
هو في حلق احنا جاوبنا فيها بالاجابه
بالتفصيل
في حلقه لو دخلت على نعرف اقتصاد هتلاقي
حلقه بتشرح اللي حاصل كله في اليابان
والاجابات عليه انما فكره الفائده السالبه
ديت يعني دلوقتي انت بتحط فلوسك في البنك
بتحط مثلا همم ما يعادل 100 دولار هناك
بتحط ما يعادل 100 دولار باليد حطيت
مليونير ياباني في البنك فالبنك في البنوك
في العاده بتقول لك انا محتاجه الفلوس دي
فانا هاديك عليهم اثنين في الميه ثلاثه%
5% على حسب ظروف البلد
مش هو عنده انكماش وعنده ظروف همم يعني
فبيقول لك والله انا مش مش عاوز اعمل حاجه
بالفلوس دي فانا هادي لك عليها ربع نصف في
المئه بلد مش محتاج الفلوس خالص لانكماشه
ما بيديش فايده على الناس عشان يجبرهم
البنك المركزي الياباني مش عاوز الناس
يديه فوايد عاليه علشان ما يحطوش فلوسهم
في البنوك وعاوز كل اللي معايا فلوس يصرفه
فلما يصرفه
ده يشجع المنتجين ينتجوا فيحصل انتعاش في
الاقتصاد الياباني فهو ده الهدف يعني طيب
وهو لما تحط في البنك ممكن تاخذ نسبه حطيت
100 فبتاخذ 5% زياده ده في العاده او ممكن
يقول لك انا مش عاوز اديك فائده خالص انا
انت تحط فلوسك هتاخذ ال 100 زي ما هي او
هتاخذها سالب انا هتحط فلوسك في مقابل ان
انا باحفظ لك عليها انا هاقتطع منها نصف
في المئه فتاخدهم 99.5 هو همم هكذا يعني
حبذا لو تتكلم على الاستثمارات السعوديه
في المغرب
حاضر ان شاء الله في اقرب فرصه بس ما شاء
الله الاستثمارات السعوديه
ما عندهمش بديل
اذا لم يطبعوا معه مش هيتعاملوا مع سوريا
سوريا مهما كانت ضعيفه هي بلد مهم محوري
في كثير من القضايا وادي انت شفت الحلقه
الاخيره بتاعت اردوغان ازاي هو احتاج بشار
الاسد محتاج يعني دمشق
ثم من هو البديل ما انت بتدور على بدائل
يعني مثلا نسائي البلد دي حكمها مين همم
يعني جماعات معارضه مثلا هي
بتتقادى رواتبها من دول خليجيه من تركيا
من دول اوروبيه هل الجماعات المتشدده مين
يعني فانت المساله لما بتقولش ان انا
باطبع لان في ميزه انا باطبع لان ده
النظام الموجود ده اللي قدر يدير الصراع
لصالحه بغض النظر انت بتؤيده ولا بتعارضه
هو قدر مهما في اضعف لحظاته انه يقنع دول
زي روسيا زي ايران ان هي تدعمه قدر ان
يلعب بالاوراق القليله اللي معه هذه
المهاره فهو يحسد على هذه المهاره ايه
اللي كانت ممكن تخلي لولاها كان الاوضاع
تبقى اسوا بكثير يعني
انت بتقول صديقنا الفارس ممدوح بيقول ماذا
سوف يحدث في البانيا هل سوف تكون بدايه
الحرب العالميه لو توضح لي السؤال اكون
شاكر انا مش يعني عارف انت تقصد ايه يعني
تحديدا هل في رايك راح يهتم يتم الصلح بين
بشار الاسد واردوغان والله كل شيء ممكن
لكن المساله بالغه الصعوبه ما انا مش عارف
اردوغان ممكن يقدم ايه لبشار الاسد
سبب زياره عبد الله بن زايد لبشار الاسد
وسبب تطبيق الامارات وسوريا مع جزيل الشكر
اول سبب يا خالد هي
امل الامارات الامارات دائما بتفكر في
بزنس
السوري بعد شويه بعد سنتين ثلاثه يحتاج
لاعاده اعمار اعاده الاعمار تحتاج الى
اموال الاموال موجوده في الامارات اموال
بتبحث عن فرص استثمار انا لن اعيد اعمار
سوريا لوجه الله تعالى
انما هعمل مشروع وسوف اديره وبالتالي انت
عندك فرص كبيره جدا لان النمو
اثنين انه علاقتك به سوريا معناها ان انت
تقدر تتفاوض مع دمشق الان في ملفات كثيره
تقلق دول الخليج يعني تفتكر مثلا لما لو
حبه السعوديه ان هي تقلل مثلا النفوذ
الايراني هناك هتتكلم مع مين هتتكلم مع
جبهه النصره ما هي لازم تتكلم مع بشار
الاسد لو انت عاوز النهارده تلعب دور في
لبنان ما هو انت محتاج دوله عندها اوراق
في لبنان يروح لبشار الاسد
هي هي دوله مازومه لكن هي دوله والدوله
لها رئيس والرئيس والعاملين معه يدوروا
اوراقهم في ظروفهم الصعبه بافضل بافضل صوب
الممكنه
وبعدين في مساحه جغرافيه في
انابيب نفط فيه انابيب غاز يمكن ان تمد في
امور كثيره يعني
في كانت استثمارات سابقه لخليجيين
الاستثمارات دي مصيرها ايه في عشرات
الامور اللي ممكن النظام يتحدث الى في
فرصه للضغط على تركيا من التعاون ما هم
كانوا في خلافات مع تركيا لما بيحبوا
يضغطوا على تركيا هيضغطوا عليها ازاي ممكن
مع من يعني بالتفاوض مع الكورد واظن ان ده
حصل في بعض الاوقات او بالتفاوض مع بشاره
يضغط على تركيا وهكذا يعني
استاذ سيد كان في حلقه عن ماذا لو حكمت
الجماعات الاسلاميه والله صح يا اسامه
والله كان لسه نفس الحلقه دي انا بتكلم
فيها بعد اصدقائي
ان انا باقول لهم الحلقه دي بقى ههه
سامحني يعني اسامه ان في مش بس التطرف هو
التطرف التطرف البابني على جهل يعني نسبه
الاميه على نسبه الجهل لما تقول للناس
مثلا معلومه بسيطه يعني انت لما تسال
استاذ اغتصاب حقيقي بجد ده بتسال الاستاذ
علوم سياسه بجد لما تسال الاستاذ في
القوانين وشاطر قل له احنا عندنا النظام
الاسلامي
ايه الاجابه ما عندناش انما الناس بتكون
دي اهانه للاسلام يعني هو احنا ما عندناش
نظام اقتصاد اسلامي احنا عندنا نظام يعني
قيمي انما ما عندناش احنا نظام زي نظام
الراسمالي بيحدد من يملك ادوات الانتاج
وكيف يتم توزيعها الى اخره ولا زي النظام
الاشتراكي بيحدد انه ادوات الانتاج في
ايدين الدوله
ما فيش مثلا قواعد بتتكلم على الضرائب
بتتعمل ازاي ولا ولا حتى في نظام الحكم
يعني امرهم شوره بينهم ده مبدا جميل جدا
انما كيف تتم الشورى وازاي دي مساله ما
فيش نصوص عليها ما فيش نظام محدد بحاجه
يعني همم مثلا يقول لك انتم طب الشوره مين
يعني الصوره الى الحاكم طب وازاي عين
الحاكم عينه ازاي واختاره ازاي الكلام ده
كله مش موجود
فالكلام في القصه ديت
يكون كلام شاقق
وكمان انك انت عاوز تبسطه وتعمله في حوالي
20 30 دقيقه العمليه بتخلي الواحد ايه
يعني يتردد
وبعدين انت شفت تجربه طالبان يعني
وتجربه ايران تجربه
همم السودان وهكذا
مساء الخير ما هو وضع الساحه همم
ماذا عن النظام العالمي الجديد ده في
حلقات كتيره يا اخونا يا ريت تي في انت لو
استاذنك لو انت كتبت انا كلمه العالم لو
دخلت على القناه نعرف اللي امه كتبت كلمه
العالم هتلاقي ان في اربع خمس حلقات
بنحاول نستطلع فيه ومن النظام الموجود
استاذنك شوفهم يعني
السلام عليكم استاذ سيد حلقه نعرف اقتصاد
عن التنبؤ الاقتصادي كانت ممتعه سؤالي بما
يخص الحلقه ذاتها هل ذلك علاقه وارتبط
بالاوضاع السياسيه الحاليه
من النظره الثانيه
والله جميله جدا جدا جدا السؤال ده لانه
ده انا يعني وانا باعمل يعني يعني
وانا بتكلم هاني كنت بكلمه ولكن احنا
عيدنا الحلقه مرتين عملناها مره وبعدين
انا حسيت ان ممكن تبقى صعبه شويه
طلبت من صديقي هاني مشكورا ان احنا نعيدها
بس في الاعاده اتحذفت ديت اذا كنت فهمته
سؤالك صح انه كل التنبؤات اللي جاءت في
الحلقه دي وفي اي حلقه سابقه وفي اي دراسه
في العالم كله من اي بتخبره المستقبل في
علم الله طيب اي بنت خبره محترمه لما
بيجيء يتنبا بيتنبا ازاي بيحط مجموعه من
السيناريوهات
ما هو مش بيقرا التيليز يعني مش بيقرا
الفنجان يعني الانجليزي بيقولوا يقرا
هو بيحط السنه ديوهات السناريوهات
المتفائله بتتبني على واحد اثنين ثلاثه في
حاجتين ما يعرفهمش سيناريو نفترض ان
الاوضاع انفلتت وروسيا ضربت اوكرانيا في
حرب نوويه واشتعل الواضع كله كل
السيناريات دي تسقط نفترض ان حصلت كارثه
ما كانتش متوقعه زي كارثه نروح بعيد ليه
زي الكافيه ما كانش فيه حد ابدا قبل 2020
او اخر شهر فيه 19 كان يسمع عنها فالحاجات
المفاجاه ديت بتضرب اي سيناريو
السيناريوهات بتتبني على لو است- لو كان
الوضع كذا لو فضل الوضع مثلا في سوريا في
مستوى منخفض لو همم انخفضت مستوى المخاطر
الجي اساسيه وهكذا اذا اشتعلت كل السنه دي
بتتبخر
انا كلمت حضراتكم قبل كده عن نظريه البجعه
السوداء مش عاوزه اكررها ثاني ولكن هي
باختصار كده انه الاحداث الكبيره
التاريخ مبيعتش نفسه فيها بتفاجئ الانسان
وكثير من يعني من الاحداث اللي في السنين
الاخره دي اتفاجئتنا يعني غيرت مجرى
التاريخ الحديث اللي احنا عايشينه وكان
توقعها مش محل اجماع يعني مثلا 11 سبتمبر
غيرت مصائر بلدان وكثيره يعني تهدد دول زي
العراق وابقى افغانستان ما كانش احد يتوقع
ما كانش حد عارف ان في 11 سبتمبر بالحجم
ده همم
كذلك همم
حتى اندلاع الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه بهذا
الشكل كان لغايه
اول فبراير رئيس اليونسكي كان شاكك ان هو
هينفذ تهديده على كوتن يعني
اليس من المفيد مروان اكثر مواصله حساب
نظام الاسد حتى يسقط ما هي مميزات نظام
بشار الاسد
بيقول لك موقف اصلا انا لما كنت بتكلم مع
السوريين في بعضهم مره لما قلت انا بشار
الاسد هو الحل يعني كلموني بعتاب شديد
بعدين انا ادركت من كلامي معهم انا باتكلم
مع سوريا من بره باتكلم على اوضاع كانها
قطع شطرنج بس الناس اللي كانوا يلموني
كانوا من الناس اللي هم تضرروا همم فقدوا
اهلهم وهجره فبيتكلموا بمراره فطبعا تعطفت
جدا وادركت ان انا لازم ان انا همم يعني
همم ما تكلمش لازم اراعي ان في اطراف
كثيره بعضهم مضارب بعضهم مستفيد انما لو
انا ناحيه العواطف يعني انت لما تيجي تقول
حاصر نظام بشار الاسد يعني معناها ان
الاوضاع على الملايين اللي شايفين سوريا
سوف تسوق اكثر واكثر واكثر هل ده يؤدي
لسقوط اي نظام التاريخ بيقول لنا لا يعني
كوبا
خدت للعقوبات اكثر من 50 60 سنه وفضل
النظام موجود والشعب هو اللي بيعاني
همم
سلام عليك احنا عندنا اسئله كثير يا ماندو
ولا ممكن
همم تحياتي لك من عرب الداخل احنا اجابنا
الاجابه همم
ساري مساء الخير ما هو وضع الصاحب
الفلسطينيه اجابناه
عندي سؤال ليس لها علاقه
همم
ليس لها علاقه بالعنوان هل صحيح ان
السويدت هما وضعوا مخطط زمني لبريطانيا
وفرنسا بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه للخروج
من المستعمرات اللي كانوا مستعمرينها
همم
[موسيقى]
مش عارف المعلومه وانا انا عارف يعني ما
اعرفش ايه يعني يعني ايه وضعوا هم ضعفوا
بالفعل بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه كانت
بريطانيا وفرنسا ضعف جدا وما عدتش قادره
على الاستمرار زي ما كانت يعني مثلا بلد
زي بريطانيا كان صعب جدا انها هتفضل
موجوده لانه ال- ال- التوسع الامبراطوري
ده عاوز قدرات اقتصاديه وعسكريه ما عدتش
بريطانيا قادره عليها فاضطر تخرج مش خرجت
لانه في انذار مثلا بلد زي فرنسا كان صعب
انه يكون موجود في المستعمرات الافريقيه
لان ده عاوز قوه عسكريه وعاوز موازنات وهم
خرجوا من الحرب العالميه الثانيه تقريبا
راكعين على الركب انما الانذار كان في
حالات معينه زي مثلا بقى في العدوان
الثلاثي على مصر 56 الاتحاد السوفيتي
والولايات المتحده في توافق نادر الاثنين
هدده الدول الثلاثه بريطانيا وفرنسا
واسرائيل وخروجي الان والا وكان في تهديد
انه للاتحاد السوفيتي لبريطاني سوف اضرب
لندن بالسواريخ
ودي قصه ممكن نرجع لها كيف اكون صحفي في
الاقتصاد وانا خريج كليه تجاره من اي كليه
ممكن تبقى
صحفي اقتصادي واذا كنت في كليه تجاره دايخ
خليك عندك مؤهلات اكثر بس انت عشان تكون
صحفي اقتصادي انت بتتكلم على امرين امور
تتعلق بمهنه الصحافه وامور تتعلق بالخلفيه
الاقتصاديه الصحفي مش لازم يكون عالم
اقتصاد بل بالعكس هو مش هينفع يكون عالم
اقتصاد لانه كده مش هيبقى صحفي الصحفي ده
وظيفته الاساسيه بتقوم في انه بيقوم بناء
للخبر عن ما صدره بشكل صحيح
ويتحاور مع المصادر عشان يقوم بنقل الخبر
بشكل دقيق لازم تكون عنده خلفيه تاهله اذا
كانت في الاقتصاد اللي بيشتغل فيه في
السياسه في السينما الى اخره فانت بتخلي
عندك خلفيه معقوله
تساعدك لو تفرغت للدراسات الاقتصاديه تبقى
اقتصادي خلاص مش هتبقى صحفي
فانت لازم تكتسب الاساسيات وانت طالما
خريج كليه تجاره عندك الاساسيات اظن كده
وممكن تنميها انما بقى المهنه نفسها مهنه
الصحافه عاوزه مهارات كتيره عاوزه انك
تكون عندك لغه عربيه معقوله جيدا يفضل
يكون عندك لغه اجنبيه يكون بتعرف تمرن
نفسك على الكتابه الثالثه على التفكير
المنطقي للاجابه على كل الاسئله همم اللي
هي بقى الاسئله الخامسه اللي كانوا
بيعلموها الطلبه انك واهم حاجه الفارق ما
بين الصحفي وغير الصحفي هي المصادر مش ان
انا ما انت ما انتاش ما عندكش اكثر اقتصاد
العلماء الاقتصاد بيعرف اقتصاد اكثر منك
ومن انت احسن واحد بيكتب لانه الادباء
بيكتب احسن منك انا اللي يميز الصحفي هل
لديك مصادر ان انت بتكلمه وتقول دلوقت انا
مثلا مثلا في ازمه في همم خبر في السعوديه
ولا سوريا ولا المجال اللي انت بتغطيه
فانت اللي بترفع السماعه وتقول تكلم مصدرك
تقول له ايه يا فلان همم الوضع عندك ايه
والمصدر مش اللي انت عندك رقم الارقام في
كل حته لكن العلاقات اللي بتخلي الناس دي
تكلمهم معك وهيثم وفيك
لماذا يترك اردوغان رغم توجهه الاسلام
الواضح ما انا اسف عبد العزيز السؤال مش
واضح ما تبعث في سؤال ثاني السلام عليكم
ازاي اصبحت الصين في 2005 اكبر مصدر للصلع
في العالم في الوقت ده كانت الصين ما
كانتش الصين اقتصاد قوي
هي بدات انت عاشرتها انت لما بتتكلم عن
اكبر مصدر يعني تالت تبقى عندها نصيب كبير
في التجاره ما هي ما زالت اكبر مصادر
السلعه في العالم في الف هي بدات انتعاشه
بتاعتها في اواخر بدات اللي هي ثوره
الاصلاح على الطريقه اللي هي الاشتراكيه
على الطريقه الثانيه او الراسماليه على
الطريقه الصينيه بدايه من 78 سنه 79 في
بدايه الثمانينات كان اقتصادها صغير جدا
قد اقتصاد اا يعني بلد همم اصغر من
ايطاليا يمكن اظن كان نفسي في 82 83 كان
قد نادر لاند اوغندا وبدا يتصل بشكل مضطرب
في 2005 كان باقتصاد جيد جدا كانت دخلت
تجاره المنظمه التجاره العربيه بتعمل من
الامريكان وكانت هي بتركز على الساعه
الرخيصه البسيطه اللي الامريكان ولا
الاوروبيين مش عاوزين نفسه فيها ثم كل ده
ما كانش قالق الاوروبيين ولا الغربيين هم
ابتدوا لما الصينيين بدا بصوا في الاقتصاد
السوفيستكيدت او المعقد
تجارب كثيره فاشله يعني في ال- ال- الليب
القفزه الكبرى ديت بتاعه ماو في الخمسينات
ادت الى مجاعه وهمم مئات الالاف ربما
ملايين ماتوا يعني لغايه ما تعلمت من
الخطا ولا
الصواب والخطا يعني التريل
ما هي الميزه همم السلام عليكم تحاول دول
الخليج اخراج ايران من سوريا
عن طريق دعم بشار الاسد ماليا لكن هل لدى
الاسد اي شيء غير الشرعيه الدوليه يستطيع
ان يؤثر بها في اللعبه في اي لعبه تقصد
دول الخليج كانت كل اللي تتمناه انه طبعا
انه بشار الاسد او اي نظام يحكم انه يكون
يعني اقل
اقل علاقته اضعف بايران لان لما تكون
علاقته بايران جيده معناها انه نفضه ما
يمتد من العراق يصل الى سوريا يصل الى
لبنان وبالتالي طبعا هيكون همم يقدر
يؤثروا في دول كثيره همم طالما سيطروا على
كل هذه المساحه
بس انا مش فاهم يعني ايه اذا كان عنده شيء
غير الشرعيه اذا كان عنده الشرعيه وهو
بيحكم فهو بيحكم في سوريا ومن يحكم في
سوريا هو رئيس دوله فيستطيع ان يساعد في
ملفات كثيره جدا ده تقريبا يعني لو وضحت
لي السؤال ممكن اوضحوا بشكل اكثر يعني ما
هي الميزه للتعدد الاقدام ما احنا كنا في
ايام الحرب البارده في تعدد اقتاب وكانت
النتيجه حروب وصراعات وخطر نووي
كلامك مظبوط بس يعني انت بتتكلم العمليه
نسبيه ان تنفرد دوله واحده بقياده العالم
ولا ان يكون في اكثر من قطب لما كان في
اكثر من قطب كانت في دول بتستفيد والدول
العربيه استفاد الدول اللي حازت معاها
امريكا وكان الروس بيحاولوا او الاتحاد
السوفيتي بيحاول يرضيهم والعكس كذلك ففي
دول استفادت لان كل معسكر كان عاوز يستقدم
المعسكر الاخر
ولو كان في اكثر بقى يعني اكثر يعني
دولتين ثلاثه اربعه يكون افضل بس صعب يعني
مساء الخير سيد شكرا جزيلا لجهودك العظيم
اود ان اعرف رايك وتحليلك الى الاوضاع في
الاردن يعني ممكن تحتاج الى وقت اكثر من
مجرد سؤال عابر اخونا حازم لكن ان شاء
الله في اقرب فرصه احنا تكلمنا على الاردن
سلام عليك استاذ سيد تحيه لك من عرب
الداخل اعتقد اجابنا مساء الخير ماذا
تتوقع في 2023 اتفاق نووي مع ايران ده
احمد
ضربه امريكيه على مواقع النووي او اعلان
ايران عن صنع القنبله والله السؤال ده
تقريبا على اثنين كان في خمس حلقات انما
ضربه امريكيه استبعدها
استبعدها
اعلان ايران عن تصنيع قنبله نوويه في 2023
استبعدها انما هم يظلوا يمتلكوا الادوات
ويخلوا الحصول على السلاح النووي ملاذ
اخير يعني
اتفاق نووي ممكن ولكن يعني مساله بالغه
الصعوبه خصوصا بعد وصول حكومه همم نتنياهو
يعني لكن لو لازم واحد من الثلاثه يبقى
التوسل اتفقنا بس ما اظنش يعني في عهد
الرئيس همم
يعني الرئيس الحالي يعني هو نفسه قال في
تصريحات وكانت مكتوبه من حوالي شهر هذا ال
ال انتهى وعجز يعني عجز فعلا يعني ان يقيم
الاتفاق فالثلاث احتمالات
صعبين يعني انما ممكن يكون
يترك زي ما هو القاء الوضع على ما هو عليه
عندي سؤال ليس لها علاقه عام سعيد هل
توقعك حرب اقليميه اخرى ما احنا عايشين
حروب كتيره يا اخونا
انا اسف مش عارف انا اسمي ابراهيم اظن
نتمنى ما يكونش فيه حروب ولكن الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده دي ممكن تاخذ
العالم الى مواجهات يعني
اللي بيخليني رغم التطرف حكومه نتنياهو ان
هي صعب مع ايران انه التكلفه عاليه جدا
في النهايه برده هما مش انتحاريين يعني
على الاقل نتنياهم نتنياهم بيقول
للمتدينين بيغاري على المتدينين اللي
عاوزين يحكموا التوراه كمان منهج لهم
وبيغالي على العلمانيين واحيانا كان
بيبارك تصريحات وتقارير صحفيه بتقول عليه
انه لا يؤمن بالله اصلا فهو عاوز يرضي كل
الناس وخلاص المهم يظل في السلطه
ويشرب السيجاره الغالي اللي هو متهم بمحصل
عليه من احد رجال الاعمال بس والله
الاسرائيليين برده يعني يعني نصوص غلابه
يعني هو افتكر نتنياهو كان مشكله شارون
كان عنده قضيه رشوه
حوالي 600 الف دولار يعني في رئيس وزراء
اسرائيل مشكلته انه حصل على 600 الف دولار
هدايا
فيبدو ان هو كان محتاج ان ياخذ بعض الدروس
من بعض الموظفين في دول يعني
عربيه مجاوره يعني موظف صغير
عندي سؤال ليس لها جبناه هل حقيقه العمله
الرقميه ستحل محل الدولار يتوقف تعريفك
ايه للعمله الرقميه لو تقصد اللي هي انه
الدولار بدل ما يبقى ورقه يبقى الديجيتال
كارنسي يبقى هو نفسه دولار برده
انما يعني تقصد مش ديجيتال انت قصدك
كريبته وكرانسيس اللي هي العملات المشفره
اللي هي ال- اا الكريبته الكارينز معلش
فكرني مندو اللي هي
العملات
الاسم ثاني زي البيتكوين ايوه زي البيت
كوين والاسيريوم انا رايي فيها من 2017
بالغ السلبيه وعملت عليها حلقات كثير ولو
تفتكروا انا يعني من 2017 تلاقوا حلقه
وهتلاقوا ثلاث اربع حلقات وراي انه هذا
العملات بتستند على تكنولوجيا جميله جدا
اللي هي البلاكيتشين ممكن العالم يستفيد
منها
النظام المصرفي في معاملات مختلفه
والاستمارت كانتريكس والعقود الذكيه
وحاجات كثير انما هي كعمله
مستحيل تنفع وده اللي انا كنت بكلم فيه
المستفيدين من العمله مش عارف ليه المساله
ما كانتش واضحه وهي كاستثمار هو مقامره
يعني انت بتجيب شيء تافه لان الناس عاوزين
يحصلوا عليه
انا رايي فيها لا هي استثمار ما فيش حاجه
فيها تنفع الناس غير ان انا اقتنعت
الكوبايه ديت مهمه لان بيكاسو كان مسكها
في منها 5000 مش عارف يعني يعني ما لهاش
قيمه يعني اصل على يعني انا يعني
همم بيها ايه البيوت على راي همم
المستثمر الشهير واضح ان انا بقى عندي
زهايمر
يعني في مستثمر شهيد اسمه خير من زين مع
الارهاق الا انا بستثمر لو انا هاستثمر في
العقارات انا عارف الناس هتسكن في
العقارات لو هتستمر في الاغذيه انا عارف
انها ساكله الاغذيه وهكذا لكن انا هاعمل
ايه بالبيت كوين دي انا مش عارف غير ان
الناس بيشتروها لانه متوقع انه هيشتريها ب
100 هتبقى ب 105 طيب انهارت وبالمناسبه
رغم ان هي انهارت على ما اقدرش شهور ايه
دلوقت الناس بيحاولوا يقنعوا ان هي فرصه
عظيمه للاستثمار لان نهارت يبقى انت
هتشتري حاجه كانت ب 100 هتشتري ب 20 الحق
اجري طب انا اشتريها ليه ب 20 ولا ب 10
يعني ما لهاش قيمه اصلا
اكيد دي وجهه نظر
وفي حد زي صديقي وانا قرمي كده مره كتب لي
قال لي انت عجوز ومش فاهم الصغيرين ان هم
ربنا
الاحتجاجات الايرانيه يعني بتذبل وتضعف
ولكن
بديه يعني ان في الحرب الدائره بين ايران
وخصومها اا الدول دي وسائل الاعلام بتركز
جامد جدا جدا جدا على المظاهرات ده حقهم
طبعا لان هم مشتركين معي ايران بس همم
يعني الحياه الكلام في مبالغه يعني
على الاقل وفقا للمعلوماتي هل مساء الخير
سيدها الاقتراب الاصول الامريكي كما تحدث
عنه العمر تشيلسكي في كتابه من يحكم
العالم او هل ستصل الولايات المتحده في
القفول لمرحله انجلترا عبد الله الجد
يعني انا اعتقد الجزء الاخير تقصد به انها
تبقى زي انجلترا اه يعني هذا هو المرشح هي
مفيش حد بيبقى في طبعا كلامنا عمري هو رجل
يقرا له ويسمع له انما اللي قاله
غيره هو كله متفق مع المنطق مع التاريخ ما
فيش قوه بتفضل الى ابد الابدين هي على راس
صداره العالم وفي تراجع في النفوذ
الامريكي لكن لسه المسافه بينها وبين
خصومها كبير وبالتالي في تراجع في قوه
امريكا اذا تراجعت لا يعني ان امريكا سوف
تنهار على الارجح كل شيء وارد ولكن معناه
ان هي ممكن تبقى سيد بريطانيا مش في
انجلترا بقى ان هتبقى دوله كبيره مهمه همم
بتحاول ان هي تاخد مكانها على الخريطه مع
الهند ومع الصين ومع دول اخرى
همم
احنا ممكن نقف بعد 10 دقائق
ايه سؤال ايه ايه السؤال انا يعني السؤال
بيحل ايه
لحظه واحده امال انا رحت
لحظه واحده
انا
معلش يا شباب
مش عارفه مش يعني مش عارف انت تقصد ليه هو
يتخلى عن الجامعات الاسلاميه رغم توجه
الاسلامي لان هو سياسي هو عاوز يبقى في
السلطه فهو يعني ممكن يبقى عنده هو يبرر
نفسه في ان انا استغنى عن كل طموحاتي في
دعم التيارات الاسلاميه والتوسع الخارجي
اللي لانه مرحله مؤقته وهرجع ثاني هو
هيقول لنفسه كده وانصاره وبيقول لنفسهم
كده ماشي خلاص انا لا افتش في النوايا لان
هو كل اللي عمله في 2010 الى لغايه مثلا
2019 20 تراجع عنه ايه العلاقه مع اسرائيل
عظيمه العلاقه مع مصر بيتمنى انها العلاقه
مع الدول الخليج بيتمناها بيحاول انه يعني
يحسن علاقاته بشكل معقول مع الدول الاتحاد
الاوروبي وهكذا يعني
هم السياسيين كده
ما هو ده اللي انا كنت باقوله انت ارجع
حلقات انا مش يعني انا ما احبش اقول انا
كنت صح لسانك الله خير الواحد بيغلط كل
يوم في تقدير الامور يعني بس يعني
انا عدد الناس اللي انا ركزت على انتقادها
لو تشوف القناه ما بتاخذش مواقف احنا بنحل
يعني ما باقولش ده كويس ولا وحش هتلاقيهم
يمكن شخصين او ثلاثه منهم اردوغان ومنهم
عمر حسن البشير طب ليه مش مثلا رئيس
الامارات ولا ملك السعوديه ولا رئيس
المصري ولا ملك المغرب ولا اي احد ثاني
اشمعنى دول يعني بالنسبه لي انا لان هم
وضفه الدين في غير محله لو ما كانوش عملوا
كده كانوا يبقوا سياسيين لهم وعليهم انا
كانت مشكلتي انا الشخصيه يعني وفقا
لتفكيري ان انا بابقى مش قادر اتحمل ان
احد
كل السياسيين بيحاولوا يخدعوا يعني يخدعو
وينو مفهوم فممكن توفق في اموره ولا توفق
فتبقى سياسي عادي انما تحاول خداع الناس
بالدين دي لعبه خطره جدا فاثنين عملوها
الرئيس السوداني والرئيس اردوغان وناس
كانوا اا قولوا انت يا بنت يعني بعض
الانصار انت جاي تنتقد الرئيس الوحيد اللي
عاوز القيم دوله الاسلام هذا الكلام ثاني
الكلام ده مش صحيح هو بالنسبه له الاسلام
ممكن يكون هو متدين انا لا علاقه لي بهذا
هو متدين هو اكثر اهل تقوى ده بينه وبين
ربنا انا باتكلم على اداءه كاسياسي هو كل
اللي عمله ان حاول يوضح الدين ليه مصلحته
ومصلحه بلده من وجهه نظر بس
والدليل على ذلك انه لو المساله كانت مبدا
مبدا بقى ايه انا اضع ايدي في ايد اسرائيل
ليه وهاعمل ايه انا معانا نتنياهو اللي
جاي ده والحكومه المتطرفه دي وهاعمل ايه
وليه دلوقتي السيسي بقى ممكن اسلم عليه طب
ما انت كنت بتقول ان ده لا يمكن اتحدث معه
وليه دول الخليج اللي انت اهنتها وشتمتها
وليه اسقطت ملف
جمال خاشقجي مع السعوديه وليه وليه وليه
حاجات كتيره يعني وبعدين هو يعني يعني ما
انت قتل يعني ما انت بتخش في الصراعات
بتقتل ناس همم لمجرد ان انت داخل في
صناعات السوريين اللي اتقتلوا في الحصار
وفي الصراعات واللي في ليبيا
والناس دي مش بشر يعني فانت بتخش في
صراعات وحكايه ان انت تقحم فيها الدين دي
مساله خطيره خطيره جدا
هل سينهار الاقتصاد العالمي قريبا الاجابه
الواضحه جدا انه يدخل فيه رقود رقود يعني
يحصل
بس كون انه يحصل يبقى انكماش عنيف يعني
يتحول الى كاسات ما فيش حد وصل للنتيجه
ديت كله بيوت الخبره لا تتوقع ذلك تتوقعون
رقودا لمده يعني جزء من العام قد يمتد الى
23 ثم تنصالح الامور وفقا للمعطيات
الحاليه
مساء الخير بالنسبه للناس اللي تهجرت من
بيوتها بسوريا ما كان السبب الرئيسي بشار
الاسد لكن اغلبهن كان والسبب بدخول
الاجانب الى سوريا واغلبهم كان اه يعني
يقصد يقول ان الاجانب هم اللي خربوا او
الدول اللي تدخلت وجهه نظر يعني تستحق
الاحترام طبعا
حلقه عنك في منازل تقريبا النساوين
اعمل يعني مش عارف مستمعين صوت احمد ماندو
يعني بيقول لي ان في حد بيلح في السؤال
يبدو ان انا مش شايفه ممكن تعمل لنا حد عن
الفرن لازم زي ما عملنا حلقه كده عن
المشكله الجنسيه
وشكرا اللي موجود حضرتك
خالد علي بيقول لي ان في سؤال انه نزل
اصدقائك انت بتختار الاسئله دي ليه
هو بيقول الاسئله دي ملحه بس واضح انهم
اصدقاء يعني ههه
حلقات عن الصين الحقيقه هتحتاج ان انا
الاقي متخصص شاطر في تاريخ الصين وفي
سياستها وهو موجودين بس همم
يعني عاوزين حد يكون كويس قوي لانه برده
اختيار الضيف دي عمليه صعبه ممكن يكون
فاهم كويس قوي بس عنده مشكله في انه يلخص
المعلومات ممكن يكون شاطر وعنده قدره
الخصيه المعلومات بس عنده اجنده واضحه في
الحماس جدا جدا للصين او للهجوم عليها لكن
والله انا حاولت وهي برده موجوده حاضر
الاستاذ خالد نسعى باذن الله
اا هل تعتقد ان الرؤساء يعانون من الارق
ويخاف
ويخافون من مستقبلهم وادانهم بالمستقبل
البعيد ده همم 100% 100% يعني وبعدين كان
مش فاكر البيت الشعر اللي كان كاتبه
شاكسبيرمن همم سنين طويله بيقول لك حتى
الرؤوس التي فوقها تاج اللي هو الملوك
يعني لا تستطيع ان تنام الليل طبعا طبعا
اكيد الارق والخوف وكده وخاصه اذا كان في
دوله مش مستقره والانتقال السلمي فيها
للسلطه صعب فدائما عنده حاله خوف
وده اللي بيعقد احيانا بعضهم بيبقى غير
قادر على الخروج من السلطه لانه اذا خرج
قد يرقى مسير
يعني مصير سيء شوشوكو
هل تعتقد ان الرؤوس السيد لماذا
الايرانيين واتباعهم الحوثيين يرفعون
شعارات الموت لامريكا وامريكا لا تحاربهم
كالقاعده وداعش ازاي امريكا ما بتحاربهمش
القاعده بتحاربهم وداعش بتحاربهم وامريكا
بتحاربهم يعني انت باني السؤال يا يوسف
على فرضيه برده انه الامريكان مش بيحاربوه
من الامريكان فردين عليهم
فاردين عليهم
عقوبات من سنه 79 من سنه 79 يبقى مر كام
سنه بتتكلم على كام سنه 443 سنه ازاي
الامريكان مش بيحاربوهم وهم كانوا عنصر
اساسي في اشعال الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه
او على الاقل دعم
الرئيس صدام حسين كانوا معظم اوقات رغم
موقفهم المحايد المعلن في دعم الرئيس صدام
حسين صحيح اللي كان فيه اا اللي هي فضيحه
امداد رينجن في
ايران اثناء الحرب باسلحه وبتعاون اسرائيل
ولكن دي كان لها اسباب وبقيت حاله
استثنائيه تعرضوا للمسائله فانت بتتكلم
على حاله استثنائيه تحولت الى فضيحه ايران
كونتراما الاصل ان هو كان بيساعده
العراقيين ضدهم يعني وما زال حتى الان
الضغط عنيف يعني ازاي الايرانيه يستشعره
ان الامريكان مثلا معهم
وهم لا عاوزين ننفذوا الاتفاق اللي هم
وافقوا عليه في 2018 ولا عايزينهم يعملوا
سلاح نووي ولا عاوزين يرفعوا العقوبات
عنهم والطلبات علشان احنا نقيم معكم
علاقات انكم تتخلوا عن صواريخهم تتخلوا عن
طموحات طموحاتكم النوويه تتخلى عن نفوذكم
عن الجامعات اللي بتدعموها في المنطقه
يعني القي كل اسلحتك
مساء الخيرات ما رايك فيما يفعله السلك في
حرب اكتوبر بالتدخل في القرارات العسكريه
وهو رئيس جمهوريه ده قصه يطول شرحها يا
صديقي يعني انما بعد العسكريين يعتقد ان
هو كان قصه خلافيه يعني
بس انت عشان جوابها لازم نحكي قصه ولا حصل
من الفريق سعد الشاذلي بالمربى نسبه
بالصدفه عندي مذكراته هنا يعني رحمه الله
قصه طويله يا صديقي والله كنت اتمنى ان
الوقت يسمح فيها لكن هو هو كان عنده راي
وكان عنده استراتيجي انا عاوز الحرب تبقى
مجرد عمليه تحريك للقضيه كان عنده قاده
عسكريين ثاني بياخدهم وفي الاخر هو برده
لما ترومان تدخل في العمليات العسكريه
واقل
القائد العسكري انا اسف النهارده الرقم
خلينا ناس الاسامي يعني بعد الحرب
العالميه اشهر قائد عسكري اللي كان بيدير
القوات هناك في اسيا
لما قال له انه الحل علشان اوقف الحرب
الكوريه ان اضرب استخدم السلاح النووي
اكله فورا هو يعني فانت برده انت القائد
وانت يعني انت المسؤول مش القائد العسكري
انت بتعين القائد العسكري فانت مسؤول عن
تصرفاته كيف يمكن التواصل معك ده انا متاح
لكل الناس محمد يمكن ان تتوس ابسط طريقه
صفحه فيسبوك عليها اللي هي الصفحه العامه
ويا ريت بلاش الصفحه الخاصه في صفحه سيد
جبيل بالانجليزي بالعربي الاثنين مع بعض
دي الصفحه العامه عيبها ايه الصفحه الخاصه
ان انا
ما هو ما بيلاقوها بس بعضهم مشكورين
بتقولي على الصفحه الخاصه اللي كانت
معموله من سنين طويله ومعظمهم اصدقاء مفيش
عليها اي تفاعل يعني انما تعال على الصفحه
العامه اذا بعثت لي رساله انا تحت امرك
ااا
وانستغرام اكونت موجود بس اكثر لو تبعث لي
على فيسبوك عشان انستجرام كل واقع تحت
نفوذ ماندو ماندو هياخذ اصدقاء بس ههه
ده الظاهر برضه حد من الاصدقاء ماندو
فبيقول لهم رايك في عوده الملكيه التونسيه
في ليبيا يعني
هيرجع لارجع ملك رجع النظام الملكي هي
المشكله مش في نظام الحكم يعني هي الفكره
ان انت عندك بلد منقسم عنده نخب منقسمه
عندها اموال بتغذي انقسامتها في نفترض
بانظام ملكي ولا جمهوري ولا كذا هي الفكره
هنا في ان الناس دي تتوافق الاول على انه
احنا هنعيش في دوله ولا هنقسمها هنقسمها
وتبقى عندي اقليم برقه واقليم فزان واقليم
يبقى في الحاله دي بقى كل بلد تبقى نظام
ملك نظام جمهوري ثم ان هو هيجيء منين
النظام الملكي النظام الملكي ده عشان يرجع
لازم يكون له فئه بتطلبه يعني مش عارف
يهبط عليها شوت
مساء الخيرات
انا استاذنكم من كتفي بسؤالين اخرين لانه
احنا بقى لنا اسئله كثير قوي
يعني انا انا بس خايف من الايطالي عليكم
انا ممكن
طيب
بس ما يكونش اصحابك
مساء الخير ماذا تستفيد الكويت من كون
عملتها لاغلى في العالم بص يا صديقي مساله
العملات دي اغلى ارخص ليست مهمه
الاول هي ليها سبب العملات لما الولايات
المتحده
كانت يعني طبعا التطور الطبيعي الدول كلها
كانت طلبته عملتها بالذهب وبعدين ثم بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه بقت الولايات
المتحده هي الدوله الوحيده الاساسيه اللي
رابطه عملتها بالذهب وبدات الدول الاخرى
ضربه عملتها بالدولار اللي هو المربوط
بالذهب عشان تعرف عملتك ايه بتقول انا
عملتي تساوي كذا دولار اللي هو مقاوم
بالذهب في بدايه السبعينات الامريكان
خسروا فلوس كثيره في طموحاتهم
الامبراطوريه وفي الحرب فيتناميه فكوا
العلاقه واصبح الدولار زيه زي غيره
الدول بدات تعيد تقييم عملتها فبدات تقيم
عملتها من اخر وزن تاريخي لها هي كان
وقتها بتساوي كذاب فوجدت ان العمله دي
تساوي مثلا ما يعادل من الذهب
ما يساوي مثلا خمسه دولار دوله ثانيه
تساوي اثنين دولار او اي عمله اخرى
فتاريخيا هي كانت اختارت انه عملتها تساوي
كميه كبيره من الذهب بدل ما يبقوا ربع
جرام يبقى نصف جرام اختيار لكن في النهايه
تاثيره ولا حاجه ما انا كموظف كويتي مثلا
الكويتي بياخذ زي مثلا انا بدي مثال همم
العامل بسيط جاي من بنجلاديش بيشتغل في
الكويت هياخذ 100$ الدولار بيساوي انا مش
عارف بيساوي كم دولار دلوقت انما نفترض
انه بيساوي مثلا ثلاثه دولار هياخذ بدل
يعني مثلا 100 بتساوي ثلاثه يبقى اخذ 300$
لو كان
العمله دي بتساوي
ونصف هياخذ ضعف الكميه لو كانت العمله دي
بتساوي سته دولار بدل ما ياخذ دولار هياخذ
50 دولار في الفكره مش ان هو كثير ولا
قليل هي العمله موجوده عند القيمه دي ده
انت اللي تندهش له اكثر الاردن ان الاردن
ظروف الاقتصاديه صعبه لكن عملته بيسعى
لتثبيتها يعني بسعر معين بقيمه كبيره
فمش مهم ان العمله الكبيره او صغيره انت
عندك الين دوله اقتصاد عظيم وقيمه اليم
دائما بارقام بسيطه يعني
يعني عمل كانه فكه الدولار كانه سن فهي
دوله بتختار الاسباب تاريخيه ومش لاقيه
سبب تخليها تغير والامور ماشيه كده يعني
المساله تطور التاريخيه
بس بشكرك معاك انت ااا دينار كويتي معناه
ان انت يعني كويس ما انت ممكن يبقى عندك
عدد قليل من الدينارات مش مشكله طيب وهمم
الريال السعودي قيمته اقل اللي كان عندك
كميه كبيره منه يعني دخلك
ترسيم الحدود مساء الخيرات ما رايك فيما
ترسيم الحدود من جانب واحد مع ليبيا هل له
ما يبرره تقصد بالنسبه لمين لاي دوله يعني
يعني بالنسبه للكود تركيه بالنسبه لمصر
بالنسبه لمين وبعدين انت هترسم ازاي من
حدود واحده يبقى انت هتختار الحدود للطرف
الاخر وتفردها بالقوه يعني
هل ثوره يناير همم هل ثوره يناير و30/06
زعلت في نمو الوعي ايوه طبعا
هل ستنهار مستقبل القضيه الفلسطينيه لا
يوجد اي مؤشرت ايجابيه ده اخونا اللي
بيسال احمد
الدراز ما هو مصير الاحتجاجات الايرانيه
انا لا اعتقد ان هي صارت ازمه عنيفه يعني
انما هم عندهم ازمات اعلى في لان الضغوط
مستمره دي ازمه بتبحث عن حل اظن ان الحل
الوحيد المنطقي ان الغرب يتفاوض مع
الايرانيين
اسم المستثمر الله يخليك شكرا يا عثمان
فعلا انا كنت باقول همم
شكرا جزيلا يا عثمان معلش سامحني
لا مش هنمشي ههه
انا لما كنت قلت على المستثمر اللي كان
بينتقد اللي هو العملات المشفره فهو اللي
كان قال العباره شكرا عثمان قال لي ان انا
يعني استثمر بها اعمل بها ايه على فكره
كان قال كلام كثير لطيف يعني انا كنت عامل
حلقه عن رايي ورم بافد اشمعنى ورم بافيت
لان ده كان اهم مستثمر في العالم يعني مش
وبعدين الشريكه ايضا اللي اسمه بقى لو
تقدر تجيبه لنا يبقى كثر خيرك برده في نفس
سنه كده في بدايه الثمانينات وكان
بيصرفت والكارين بانها همم ثم في ايران
كلام فارغ يعني
انضافه كان ملخص القصه قال لهم انتم
مصدعني واحد همم هو بيعمل حفلات خيريه
كثيره عشان تحضر الحفله وتقرب منه فبتتبرع
بمبلغ كبير اتبرعوا بمبلغ كبير عشان
يقعدوا جنبي على الترابيزه وقعدوا ثلاث
ساعات يكلموا وقاعد يفهم ايه هو الكريب
وبعد كده اللي هو انا مش شايف غير كلام
فاضي
غلط انتم بتكلموني على كلام فارغ ثم يعني
نفترض ان انتم بتقولوا عليه ده
ممكن يكون لي قيمه بعد 130,000 سنه انا
همم ولمبافط بالاقي صعوبه في اداره الاصول
التي افهم فيها فلماذا ادير اصول لا افهم
فيها واشك ان في اي حد بيفهم فيها على
الله يعني انما على فكره للمره الثانيه
وقال الثالثه هناك جماعات مصالح وراء
الترويج للكريبته
الناس دي بتاخذ فلوس البزنس بتاعهم مستقر
مرتبط بها فهو عاوزها تستمر وفي صحفيين
همم جهاد واا اقتصاديين واا بيعملوا لان
هم انا جاء لي عرض جاء لي وظيفه من شركه
قالوا لي من حوالي سنه وشويه انه نتعاقد
معك وتبقى انت المتحدث باسم شركتنا اللي
هي معنيه بنشاطين ثلاثه من الكربون
وهيدفوا ما بالك كويسه بس انا اعتذرت لان
انا يعني تبقى يعني همم
انا بعتبرها نصب على الناس يعني سامحوني
مساء الخير سؤال شخصي هل انت شيعي او سني
والله سؤال ده مش حلو امين يعني الاسئله
اللي تتعلق بالدين دي اسئله يعني غير
مناسبه وربما لو سالت ناس في بلدان اخرى
ممكن يعني تكون الاجابه عنيفه ولكن
عموم الرد عليك انا مصري في بلد ااه
الغالبيه العظمى فيها من السنه فانا مسلم
مولود مسلم سني لكن احترم السنه واحترم
الشيعه واحترم المسيحيين واحترم بالبوطيين
طب والكلام ده كلام فارغ يعني انا بابصلها
لك على النحو التالي صاحب هذا الدين واحد
عاوز يتقرب الى الله بطريقته انت لو مختلف
معه خلاص قل له يعني والله انا ادعوا لك
بالهدايه لو انت شايف انما لا تؤذي» لانه
هو عاوز يتقرب الى الله بطريقته وما فيش
احد بيمتلك الحقيقه لو بصيت للناس بالشكل
ده هتحترمهم جميعا وتقدرهم الا اذا كان
بيعتدي على حريتك
المشكله ان انت بتعتدي على حريات الاخرين
او تصنفهم يعني لكن انا جبت السؤال علشان
همم
عندي سؤال هل العالم بالفعل في حاله جنون
ويتجه للاسوء في حاله غير مسبوقه من هذا
لطالما كان الوضع الطبيعي سؤال حلو جدا
والله يا محمد والسؤال ده لا العالم مش
دائما دائما العالم في صراع لكن في اوقات
بتبقى معقوله عاوز تعرف ايه مثال المعقول
ان ما فيش كوارث هائله بتهدد العالم
واستقراره بشكل كبير ده خذ من فتره 90 ليه
فتره همم 2000 22 بس اثناء الازمه الماليه
العالميه عندك صراعات صغيره يعني ايوه في
بلد زي العراق تم تدميره بلد زي افغانستان
بس احنا عندنا العالم خذ مثلا ال 100 سنه
اللي سبقت الحرب العالميه الاولى من بعد
حروب نابليون لغايه الحرب العالميه الاولى
فتره هدوم استقرار فالعمليه دائما في
صراعات انما الصراعات حرائق صغيره يتم
اطفئها والمعانه تنحصر في بلد او اثنين
غير لما يكون
الصراعات والازمات الاقتصاديه بالغه العنف
والله انا مقدر طبعا رغبتكم ان احنا نكمل
ونستمر انا
شاكر ممتنك كثر الف خيركم ولكن
في اا القول اللي بيقوله سيد المسيح النفس
راغبه والجسد ضعيف انا اتمنى اكون موجود
ولكن ال- اا يعني يكون صعب معلش سامحوني
انا شاكر جدا جدا جدا وممتم اليكم يا رب
تكون الحلقه افادتكم وان شاء الله لكل
الاخوه عندنا لقاء اخر اذا لم اتمكن من
رؤيه سؤالك استاذنك بس بكر شويه وانضم
الينا في الاول بحيث تكون همم
الفرصه اكثر خلال الساعتين اللي احنا
قضيناهم اي مقترحات اي شيء اكون شاكر
تبصله معي او تواصلوا مع احمد هو عنده
اكثر من اكونت وهو اشطر مني في التعامل
وهو همم يعني كمان هو كمان يفيد ناس كثيره
جدا في اي حد مهتم به وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي انت همم اسم الاكونت ليه اسم
غير احمد همم
ده جريت ماندو جريت اللي هي جريت وماندو
ام اي ان تي او اللي مهتم ان هو يستفيد
همم
ازاي دور صفحاته على الفيسبوك وبدي نصايح
ومحاضرات وطبعا ممكن يعني تتواصلوا معي او
معه مباشره
[موسيقى]
ذكاء الصناعي اكتفي بالاجابه بسيطه انه
القناه على ده عدد من السياسيين ومراكز
الابحاث بانه سوف يكون اعظم تغير في تاريخ
البشريه بعد اكتشاف النار
لانه سوف يغير كثيرا جدا جدا من اول
الحياه على كل المستويات في حلقه على ذكاء
الصناعي وكان عباره عن لقاء مع الدكتور
احمد بهاء انما ان شاء الله نتمكن ونعمل
اكثر من حلقه عن الذكاء الصناعي شاكر جدا
لكم ربنا يسعد ليلتكم ويسعدكم
واشكركم والى لقاء اخر باذن الله ملحوظه
قبل ما اختم احنا عملنا اكثر من حلقه
اجابه على اسئلتكم مش بس على نعرف ولكن
على نعرف اقتصاد من فضلكم ادخلوا ولو كان
عندكم حاجات تتعلق بالاقتصاد يطلبوها ونوف